[Music]
[Music]
experiments were done up the street and
if you walk across through building nine
into building 13 you can find the
offices where Bob Laughlin yelled at me
and his thesis adviser John Joe
innopolis for many years we really we
really feel as though this is a family
affair and we're really delighted that
Bob and Dan and Horst all agreed to come
and speak today I want to express thanks
on behalf of the physics department to
Dave Lister the vice president for
research and Dean furs for for research
for helping to support this and for the
Frances bitter magnet lab Bob Griffin
also helped support it and I especially
want to mention the David Harris lecture
fund David Harris was a student at MIT
and before his death he discussed with
his family a memorial that he would like
and and he wanted a memorial which would
be a living memorial as opposed to
hardware or bricks and mortar and so he
his family endowed a fund which provides
resources for us to bring distich
distinguished lectures to the physics
department each year and this year we're
especially delighted that that's being
used to help support the symposium so
now I'd like to call upon Dave Lister
who wanted to say who would like to say
a few words Dave
thank you Mark it says here another
welcome I'm not sure you need another
welcome but I think the reason I was
asked to do this is to indicate that
this lecture series is an important part
of the intellectual life of the
Institute as a whole and then what's
happening this afternoon is also
important to the rest of the Institute
and not just the physics department so I
welcome you I was thinking about this
prize a little bit and the thing that
the idea that popped into my head is
that very often those of us who do basic
science experimental basic science
especially Oh an enormous debt of
gratitude to technology but we seldom
acknowledge it publicly but it's it's
very important and this Nobel Prize
would never have happened without some
very important pieces of technology
sometimes the basic scientists have to
develop the technology themselves and
here there were I see there were three
important technological ingredients the
first was these very special materials
with very high electron mobility and
those were developed by Horst and
together with art Gossard at Bell
Laboratories without those the
experiments could not have been done
secondly the experiments required very
high magnetic fields and those happen to
be available at the Frances bitter
laboratory and no place else in the
country and so the experiments were done
here I think Peter Wolfe would be
telling us more later this evening for
those who were there about it and the
third bit of technology is something
that people referred to as a wet
technology they me it was the unusual
brain of Bob Laughlin who happens to be
able to think about things in a way
different for most of us and therefore
it was able to explain this so I think
it's going to be an interesting
afternoon in fact it's going to be a
real intellectual treat
and I will sit down so that Bob Griffin
can proceed and we can get it started
thank you
well thank you Mark and Dave I I'm here
because I'm director presently the
director of the Frances better magnet
laboratory and as many of you know being
director of the magnet lab has been like
being captain of a in the last few years
at least being captain of a ship sailing
on a really pretty rough sea some people
one of my colleagues described us like
being captain of the Titanic even but
we've had some very good experiences
nevertheless during the last few years
and many of those were associated with
visits from horse Dermer and Dan Suey I
mean we were very closely connected of
course with the experimental aspects of
the fractional quantum Hall effect as
Dave Lister just mentioned the
fractional quantum Hall effect was
actually discovered at the Frances
bitter national magnet laboratory at
that time and it was actually
approximately 18 years ago today
yesterday rather I don't know if you
realize that October 7 1981 and we're
converging to the opinion that was the
experiment may have been done in self or
of the magnet lab maybe Horst and Dan
can comment on that later on but we owe
Horst and Dan a very great thank you a
very big thank you they have been an
enormous help to the lab and I think
everybody at the lab particularly myself
really appreciates what they have done
for the lab perhaps more than what ever
we did for them and so I would like to
express the gratitude of the laboratory
and its members to both of those
individuals for all of the nice
interactions we've had and also to add
our congratulations to everyone here on
the award of the 1998 Nobel Prize
thanks Bob
so now I'm going to call on Raya Sheree
who was a postdoc with horse tumor at
Bell Labs before he came to the MIT
faculty to introduce horse
well it's a pleasure and an honor for me
to introduce Horst horse has been at
Bell Labs since completing his PhD at
the University of Stuttgart in 1977 and
he started at Bell as a postdoc in a
year later became a regular member of
technical staff and following sort of a
meteoric rise three or four years later
became a department head headed the
famous semiconductor physics department
which is where the transistor was
invented and he became after that
director of physics research in 1991
he's now a professor at Columbia and he
still holds an adjunct director position
at Bell by the mid-1980s when I was in
grad school horse was already quite
famous in fact I remember one of the
older students in my lab having boasted
I saw Horst Armour so and a lot of other
adjectives came along with that but you
can imagine that how thrilled I was when
he chose me as a postdoc in 1990 so the
first thing I noticed you know coming
into the lab was just an amazing amount
of inventiveness and a little bit of
outrageousness that I think led horse to
do a lot of great things the first or
second day in the lab he asked me can
you solder sure I can solder and I
thought it was just soldering wires
together what he meant was can you sit
up on this table on top of a stool and
solder a couple wires of solder under a
microscope on the end of a long probe
that we used a low temperature probe and
solder little microscopic wires on this
sort of flimsy setup and the idea was we
had an idea well he had an idea for a
very novel experiment and I was a little
bit reticent about sitting up on the
stool so he showed me first that it
could indeed be done so it's this kind
of spirit that the that made it just a
tremendous amount of fun to be there way
back when he was a postdoc he invented a
technique for growing Alta pure semi
conductor materials called modulation
doping and this Discoverer this
invention has what was one of the key
items I think in finally giving rise to
the discovery of a fractional quantum
Hall effect that he and Dan Suey did
here is you've all heard and this kind
of structure actually it has had some
technological relevance and that if you
have a cell phone
you've got transistors made out of this
kind of ultra-pure material that horse
invented and some of these ideas that
he's had in retrospect they seem so
simple and maybe even obvious but of
course before you make the discovery
before you have the idea it's not at all
obvious and horse is known I think for
for for just seeing with amazing clarity
what needs to be done
here's another sort of outrageous thing
that he did he invented a technique
called pls cleaved edged overgrowth
which you take a wafer that you grow
it's a very thin wafer you cleave it
inside of inside of a machine this use
for growing these wafers and you
actually grow on this thin edge of the
wafer
okay this allows you to make it turns
out so perfect one dimensional
structures and the technique itself is
difficult enough but on top of this when
I came to his lab he's actually doing
lithography on this half millimeter edge
so imagine doing lithography the kind
that's normally done on big
semiconductor wafers on on a very tiny
edge and I was just amazed at the
outrageousness of this quest he actually
made it work and has done beautiful 1d
experiments experiments on
one-dimensional wires since I also here
I'm blessed with being near Peter Wolfe
who was director of the magnet lab at
the time of Horst and Dan made the
discovery and I just love listening to
his stories about horse and Dan during
that time and how they when they
discovered the fractional quantum Hall
effect first of all they're working
inside of a very noisy big magnet with
those giant currents running through the
spinner magnet water
through it making the whole system
vibrate this bore is about two
centimeters wide now imagine you have
room temperature outside this bore
inside the bore you want it to be 50 mil
Kelvin so you somehow have to develop a
refrigerator that cools your scent
samples down to 50 mil Calvin horse and
Dan did it and that of course is what
got them the prize so you can see how
this kind of inventiveness it's just
critical to this kind of discovery
here's another story about the first day
on the job with horse he has tremendous
energy and you see this in the way he
walks because you just can't keep up
with him so what I would notice is that
he walked so fast that I would I
couldn't walk as fast so I'd end up
running a few steps than walking a few
steps and running a few steps and this
is how we progress to lunch every day
during my two years at Bell Labs after
horse became director and that was after
my first year at Bell he after after a
year he would still come down to the lab
and he would do things like help me
change the pump oil you know what a
completely mundane job for Nobel
prize-winning director he's getting up
because he's getting sick of this but
but but you could see you could see in
him that there was there was a real love
of just being in the lab all right let
me let me end with this horses received
every Physics Award imaginable the
Buckley Prize the Nobel Prize the
Franklin medal and he's in the National
Academy of Sciences he's truly I think
extraordinary and where a person is it's
just the thrill to have him here if just
for the day your horse
[Applause]
this is on is this on yeah ray you
haven't gotten any briefer but thanks
very much I'm it's just too much on us
thanks thanks sorry I I must say I you
hear more and more of these things and
you sort of start wondering about
yourself but all I can say I'm a very
lucky guy that has worked with
tremendous people and not just
collaborators but also then in the form
of postdocs and raise one of those and
there are several others around and they
give me all this credit and it's just
not true these guys that did it and that
races help changing pump oil is very
easy it's the only thing I can do it's a
it's a pleasure to be back at what was
for many years our part-time home not
far down here sort of a place you really
wouldn't want to call home when you walk
into it it's a loud noisy environment
but then Sue and I came there for many
years doing our experiments eating cold
pizza and drinking warm coke looking at
data on chart recorder coming out and
singing together with our our of grad
students funny songs from Monty Python
it was a real good time for a few years
that well actually it must be about a
decade that we came up here so it's a
it's a pleasure to be back at MIT it
doesn't mean that I haven't been back in
the meantime visiting old friends and
many of them are in the audience there's
actually too many to go through one by
one if I do it I know I'm going to
forget one of them so I better don't so
we have three hours I'm not sure the
audience how long you gonna hold out for
three hours but I have the advantage of
having the first hour and Bob has the
last dude that's my first can I take
this off yeah no almost not you can't
imagine we're doing a lot of these
recently
actually the two of us Bob and I have
been on the tourists through Scandinavia
and we started feeling very much like
these gentlemen it's just a good one
that and it hasn't it hasn't stopped
much since then I'm looking very much
too forward to Wednesday next week I
hope that some of the burden is going to
be taken off from us but I'm afraid it's
not going to be condensed metaphysics it
still will be rough going
in fact when I told Bob that I I did
this when we went to Stockholm and I had
only the pieces with me I told Bob that
I would be doing this and he said yeah
and I know who's gonna be Pavarotti sir
I told him of course the best so I mean
actually longer there's this vein I
thought there's this of course all this
is it's a great honor and it's a
wonderful wonderful weekend we had a
very good time and how good the time we
had perhaps shown of this one here you
come in in the morning and you're sleepy
and not yet shaved and washed because
you get off the plane and so they want
you to take a photograph in front of the
king this is the king yeah no I tell you
why we'll be laughing and you know why
we're laughing the viagra jokes were old
by then so they get you in front of the
camera and what all photographers do is
you're never close enough right
photographers always do them because
they have one under the camera they do
it like this so they wanted us to stand
closer together and you know Bob and I
say I can't he's after all in the middle
there and it's not so easy to get so Bob
started out complaining is that what do
you want so the two of us just blurted
it out and you see this is Louise
ignarro the one of the physiology Prize
winners and he looks around is just
totally flabbergasted how poorly how
badly physicists
can behave in front of the Kings of
course I mean it was that one that ended
up in the newspaper the next day my
fellow countrymen have have had had good
good fun with me because in fact there
was all this raised the sort of the
question is he German or is he not can
we can we count him as one of ours or
not and this this question actually goes
on and particularly because my umlaut I
haven't whom loud my name and I dropped
it when I came to this country because a
good friend of mine as Michael Schluter
is no more but he told me drop you home
loud because a the typewriters doesn't
have it they don't know what to do with
it and then the smart guys
I put an e afterwards so half of them
dropped the umlaut the other half puts
an ear after you oh then you appear
twice in the alphabet and it's not next
to each other so I dropped my umlaut but
now of course they have found them loud
again and you wouldn't believe in the
last ApS meeting I was in twice once
with and once without him none but this
is what actually somebody from loose and
sent me the next day in the mail from
Germany this was this is of the
equivalent of the I don't know daily
news probably this was a front page of
it and when I got this in the mail I my
first reaction is to fly home and kill
my mother because that's me as a
five-year-old playing Indians and
cowboys in Germany then of course no
concept of the whole thing but I thought
my mother I'd give him that picture but
indeed they had shot it off the wall
because it's hanging together with my
little brother who's here that they cut
out it's hanging on the wall in my for
my parents living room yeah in German
they see this says this is here the
referring to the picture our Nobel
laureate and then it says under here
already as a boy he built a toy train
with a rocket propulsion which is
actually which is true which is true
what it doesn't say there is here some
very small letters here and
by the way it blew up in his hand and
ripped off his thumb which is also true
this is a long time ago I have no
problem with this anyway but it
certainly doesn't doesn't show me as a
very good experimentalist so it was a
little bit awful well enough of the of
the jokes let me let me try to to talk a
bit about the fraction quantum Hall
effect and see how far I get in and I
then said that however far I get he
takes the second half so I want to talk
about fractional charges and fraction
quantum numbers and when they give you
sort of an impression what this whole
thing about the way I judge the audience
is actually that most of you actually
know everything about it and I might as
well sit down but after all you paid my
ticket up here so why don't I deliver I
don't think I have to say much to
disorient about condensed matter physics
but I think let me let me just perhaps
pick up at one point along this sort and
that is one of the big problems nowadays
in condensed matter physics is
electron-electron correlations meaning
that electrons are strongly interacting
of course because they are charged and
taking into account the correlation the
motion between electrons as its forced
upon them by the other electrons around
them is a very difficult problem most of
our life we get away with with with very
crude approximation so number one forget
it just don't take into account swittel
twiddle a little bit around as a math
and and and with a dispersion relation
and you're done but in some cases
electron electron native Direction is
everything for example in
superconductivity is everything mediated
by phonons there and what I want to show
you is another case where electron
electron interaction is everything and
it's only electrons this time around
electrons in 2d that really show very
strange behavior indeed in fact the
strange behavior that it shows and it's
just a pool of two-dimensional electrons
nothing else in a magnetic field you get
fractional charges out which was of
course a big surprise there new electron
quantum liquids fractional quantum
numbers
flux magnetic flux can be attached to
electrons at least it looks as if it
were attached to electrons new particles
are popping up that can sometimes be
fermions and bosons depending on what
magnetic field you have huge magnetic
fields as big as the ones that you get
next door or got next door and you still
get a good fraction of them next door
can apparently disappear 10 Tesla
something like there's a million times
the Earth's magnetic field disappears
and the carriers that you have seem to
be moving along as if there were no
magnetic field there's a mass popping up
which has nothing to do with the mass of
the electron and they may be super
conduct in some sense let me see whether
I get to this give you a bit of an
impression we're working on
two-dimensional electron systems and you
can create two-dimensional electron
system in 3-dimensional words or was
that an interface between two always an
interface between two things so you
could do it on the surface of helium and
it is being done on the surface of
helium on the surface of anything
typically things are dirty I this is no
comment about your floor it's it's it's
just dirty in the sense microscopically
that they're dangling bonds where the
electrons get stuck so it turns out
actually the best way to make a
two-dimensional electron system is at
the interface between two things between
two semiconductors inside the
semiconductor the technique to do this
was actually developed invented in the
70s by all show at Bell Labs and it's a
high vacuum evaporation technique where
basically evaporate two semiconductors
on top of each other in this case so
this is a high vacuum chamber and the
evaporate gallium and arsenic gives you
one semiconductor gallium and aluminum
than arsenic gives you another
semiconductor that's all you need to
know and you grow it on a substrate
which provides a template so that the
atoms go into the right place otherwise
it's just like ball bearings in the
sense otherwise it would be a random so
you provided nice underlying lattice for
it to grow and as you know in order for
semiconductors to conduct you have to
throw some dirt into it you have to dope
in them and in this case actually
silicon becomes the dopant so silicon is
the stuff that gives up an addition
electron that then can move around in
the material the way this locks
like this this is about 2 inch diameter
what is dark you disregard these things
up they actually they have something to
do with what Ray brought up and that is
this cliff that you over cross it's not
important it's just this part down here
this is the wafer so they're shiny
semiconductors look like a silicon wafer
basically and the reason that a black
here is because the backpacker
background was black but it's a shiny
surface of about 2 inch diameter which
then has been grown by MBE and the
important aspect of this is that you
have incredibly controlled in the Z
direction you can grow these layers one
layer after the other so what you see
here in a cross-section is four layers
of gallium arsenide four layers of
aluminum and arsenide four layers of
gallium arsenide this is the black and
white stripes you have a control this
was in one atomic layer and this is so
so you form these layers that fluctuate
by not more than one atomic layer so
about an angstrom there's at the
flattest surfaces that you can create
with say a control of really one layer
you know you can stop at five or at six
so it's seven layers and this this
technique that was developed and
invented in the 1970s we had then used
in order to make very high mobility
two-dimensional electron system in three
dimension there's sort of a catch-22
when you dope something you throw in the
silicon which gives off the electron
that then moves through the
semiconductor but you left with the
charged impurities of which the electron
then very often bounces off so yes you
introduce carriers but you also
introduce the scattering for it in 3d
there's a you hardly can get around it
in 2d you can because in 2d you can put
the electrons at one layer and the third
in the other layer and therefore they
hardly see each other and this is the
method to do it it's called modulation
doping which is so the green is one
semiconductor the blood the blue is the
other semiconductor you put the
impurities into the green semiconductor
and they wander over into the blue
semiconductor because they're they have
find lower energy this is a quantum well
of about a hundred angstrom thick
and the electrons now can move in this
plane but they cannot move in the Z
direction because they are tightly
confined in fact they're so tightly
confined that quantum mechanics plays an
important role they're confined that you
see the first bound state and the second
bound state and they are separated by
about let's say 10 milli electron volts
so quantum mechanics is an important
aspect of this if you only have the
lowest state occupied and not the second
one the electron in the Z Direction has
no degree of freedom it's just it's just
tight it cannot do anything but it can
move in the XY plane
easily in fact very readily because it's
such a nice plane and then if the
impurities are away from it so you get a
very high mobility two-dimensional
electron system in which the electron
can run for very long distances before
they scatter is anything the electron
density is about 10 to the 11 which
makes about an electron every 300
angstrom something like this typically
10 to the 11 you can vary but that's a
typical density that you will find
mobility is now nowadays as high as 10
million in fact last week though it's a
week before of two weeks ago we had a
record of 23 million mobility which is
unheard of I mean this river I show you
a little bit more about this you may not
understand what mobility means but it's
a mean free path of about 100 microns in
fact 20 million is about 200 microns so
the electron travels in this plane for
about 200 microns without bouncing to
anything and 200 microns is really big
about well the thickness of your
fingernail she doesn't look so big but
on a microscopic scale and on a
lithographic scale what we can do
nowadays it is a huge mean free path and
it's these two dimensional electron
system which then we can regard as a two
dimensional metal there basically
nothing else but that was a very long
mean free path so it means that the
lattice behind it hardly plays any role
it's like a two dimensional electron
system just in free space now this
technique was invented around 1978
something like this by these 4 guys and
I'll show it to you for two reasons the
one is sort of a historical picture in
terms of MBE machines this is how MBE
machines look then
in fact what you did is this is for this
is a very high vacuum these days you
still open it up let all the air in
stuck your sample and pumped it out
overnight and the next morning you did
your gross you don't do this anymore
he's much cleaner than that the people
standing around here is Willie Whitman
art Gossard rainin go and this is me in
an earlier incarnation standing around
the MB machine for the photographer and
the the important part was the other
important part where I'm showing to you
is our gossip gossip was a person that
grew the sample on which we then
discovered the fraction quantum Hall
effect and this was the first time
mobilities went as high as 90,000 and
that one made it all possible and I mean
it brought it actually about so the
sample is that absolutely it's the most
important ingredient to to all of this
and art Gossett and his assistant Billy
Whitman they grew the sample and it's
really unfortunate they didn't they
didn't share with us in that price they
shared with us in some previous prices
but not in this one
and I say it's unfortunate because I
think for us condensed matter physicist
materials is it's just the most
important aspect of our work the people
that have first hand on materials are
the ones that very often I had in the
science that they're doing because it's
really the materials that gets them to
this initial step from where you then
can start playing so arts and and MBE
technology is a very important important
aspect of all of this so what you end up
with then is a two-dimensional electron
system whereby the separation of
electrons from the dopant impurities and
then the suppression of scattering from
those is there any kind of a pointer all
right you get very high mobility at very
low temperatures you get very long mean
free path so it looks a bit like a
billiard table in in two dimensions
electrons can only move into them oh
there is one yeah right I should this is
this little guy in there great thanks
let me show you how an NB machine looks
nowadays and the people that are running
it this is this is the crew nowadays
that is making this 25 million of 23
million mobility sample actually the
most important guy Lauren Pfeiffer and
his assistant Ken West this is Kirk
Baldwin who's an assistant with me and
this is a Miriah Coby was a post look at
the time so now the MBA machine is about
that big and you use much cleaner
methods in order to get to such high
mobilities but again these are the
important guys to which we owe
everything i'm very often being asked
why at Bell Labs wide fractionate
charges is it ever going to be in the
telephone system and my only answer to
this is only gonna make our vacuum
cleaners run only one third speed and
that's about all you bet and it's a joke
with so and fractional charges will not
have I don't see fractional charges
having any kind of application in there
even in the long run but there's another
aspect of all of this work which has an
application and that's this one out of
exactly the same material or the SEC
exactly the same material in which we
discovered then I discovered the
fractional quantum Hall effect out of
the same material you can make field
effect transistors it just looks like
it's this is what is in every PC is a
MOSFET never mind what it is this thing
just looks the same but it's another
material and this specific technique of
modulation doping creates mobilities
that are much higher than here and
contact resistance are lower and all of
this so these transistors or transistors
made out of this materials are the
fastest and lowest noise transistors in
the world still today this is one built
by Fujitsu who actually was one of the
first that made a microstrip microscopic
transistors are out of this never mind
what the structure is but this is the
fastest lawns night resistor that you
can get and it's in any of those around
the world each one has one of those
radio telescopes this is not a very big
market there's just about
the hundred or hundred two hundred
around the world so he cannot make money
with that but you can make quite a lot
of money with these things so a lot of
these high frequency to [ __ ] Hertz
telephones that cellular phones have in
the front end which is well I don't know
if the microphone is a front end maybe
up there have one of these hemp
transistors for very good performance
and the base stations have it in there
so there's another part of this of this
modulation doping which is not basic
science but really technology and I I
feel very fortunate that on one side
this this modulation doping that we
invented led to two very basic science
and on the other side it also led to an
application and it's not so that the one
came off to the other I think it's an
important lesson and we're not the first
two to teach this lesson in a sense but
all the materials not the first two
teachers lesson that is that it's not
always an invention fundamental physics
and then there's application very often
these things go in peril and very often
actually they go backwards because the
progress in technology so important for
us to do the next step in in science too
okay let's get a little bit closer to
the fraction quantum Hall effect if you
have such a system particularly if it's
semiconductors the easiest thing you can
do a part formation that it's resistance
is to measure the whole resistance all
it is it's like a resistance measurement
but in addition you put a magnetic field
on so this is a two dimensional electron
system you run a current down it and you
put a magnetic field onto it
then you measure two characteristic
voltages the one is along the current
paths the other one is across the
current path the one is nothing else but
the resistance and the other one should
be zero as long as there's no magnetic
field because the thing is symmetric
when you put a magnetic field on it then
you push the carrier's to one side
because of the Lorentz force so you
build up a voltage eventually it built
up a voltage from one side the other
that's what you measure and these the
voltage that you measure divided by the
current because it's proportional to it
so if you double the current you get
double the voltage so you normalize it
to the current you get a resistance the
characteristic resistance which is
called the halt resistance and as Edwina
Hall has already figured out in the last
century I showed this neck
next view graph rxy this resistance is
proportional to e to the magnetic field
and inversely proportional to the
carrier density in the material so it's
a wonderful way of measuring carrier
densities in material particularly in
semiconductors because you see the small
end the easier it is to measure the
small and the bigger this number is and
typically carrier concentrations are
small in semiconductor as compared to
metals so this is a wonderful way of
measuring carrier concentration as it's
an industry standard so this is the
first thing you do and we've done this
of course but Edwin Hall had done this
already in the last century this is why
it's called Hall effect he was a
graduate student by the way at Johns
Hopkins in nineteen eighteen seventy
nine when he discovered that in a very
thin foil of gold he just did this
experiment that I showed you and this is
the result here if oh in fact there's
another aspect to all of this which I
always enjoy in this is for all of us
that are writing papers that have to be
three and a half page and not any longer
it's interesting to read this
introduction here right we have to fight
with every word take a word out and make
an acronym out of it so that you save
another five words this starts out with
sometimes during the last university
year while I was reading Maxwell's
electricity and magnetism made by that
time you had already we're already over
your page limit nowadays the the other
the other aspect is just like it is
expensive nowadays to publish color
figures it must have been expensive then
those days to publish any kind of a
figure so his results are here only in
form of a table so I had to sit down and
for the first time plot up Edwin Hall's
data and here's had been told data now
on a graph here it's plotted this is the
hall of what we could call nowadays the
hall resistance it's actually a current
through the gold leaf divided by the
currents room magnetometer versus
magnetic field in units of the Earth's
magnetism one does not know what this
units are but one knows that it's
proportional to the magnetic field so
that's fine so this magnetic field this
is a hole resistant and you see those
are his data it's a very nice straight
line just as well as we we know and of
course I'm since then this experiment
has been done in many ways by many
people and it's a perfectly nice
straight line
the slope of this line here gives you
the carrier density of the material the
steeper it is the less carriers are in
there so this was the status until 1980
when Klaus won Clinton came along and
told us that this is not so at all in
fact in two dimensions it's not so at
all this is the original resolved
Clinton pepper and Dora in 1980 and it's
plotted in a different way than I do in
all would have plotted it so I show you
the way similar data it's not the same
data but similar data locks if we plot
it like Edwin Hall plotted it magnetic
field Hall resistance this is the hall
resistance yeah I talked about the other
one in a second so Edwin all would have
told her there's a straight line and
Klaus and creatine found of course this
is a very nice example the steps were
much weaker when he saw him but there
are lots of steps in there this is not
all a straight line the steps are in
there and not only are they steps very
flat and sometimes very wide but they're
also also quantized two units of AGOA
squared to an accuracy nowadays of a few
parts and ten to the eight so a few
parts in a billion almost right a few 10
billions accurately quantized to this
ratio of corn a tional constant this
came as a big surprise facts there are
some Inklings in the theoretical
literature that sort of first saw this
in some sense but not really pointed it
out you experimentally should and it was
it was obscure but clouds weren't
listening discovered this actually at
the magnet lab in Grenoble the sort of
sister institution in Europe so this is
not all all a straight line but it's
plateaus and it's quantized and I'll
show you also what the resistance does
as a function of magnetic field that's
the other property it looks like the
derivative of this whenever this is flat
it's actually a deep minimum and then
when it makes a transition you get a
spike out of it so the magneto resistant
looks like the Horace is like the
derivative of the whole resistance I
show you this because later sometimes
show you these data because they're sort
of more dramatic than even the whole
resistance but it's it's the same the
origin is
it has the same origin here comes my to
view graphs explanation of the integral
quantum all effect if you put a magnetic
field on a two-dimensional electron gas
then the electrons classically perform
rotary motion around the magnetic fields
a quantum mechanically this is just a
mnemonic oscillator so this is my
quantum mechanical oscillator and then
there are bound States in there and
there's only a certain number of bounds
well there's an infinite number actually
but they're discrete and there's nothing
in between so the electron can be in
this state in this state on this day and
nothing in between so in a two in a
three dimensional electron gas there is
actually something in between but in 2d
there's nothing in between and therefore
there's only allowed States at this
energy at this energy and at this energy
and nothing in between
I forget the spin left the spin out for
most of my talk it just complicates
matters here but it's very easy to take
it to account the other aspect of it of
this conversation is that the number of
electrons you can fit into a square per
one of these Landau levels as they are
called is only a ratio of natural
constant and proportion to the magnetic
field so you take if you take this this
wave function you make sort of a size
out of you take a cookie cutter and just
cut out see how many fit in there and
you see that the number of electrons per
level is just e times B over H and it's
independent the mass it's independent of
the app self epsilon of the materials in
depend of everything it's just e be only
proportion to the magnetic field so the
integral quantum Hall effect actually
happens when I fill up an exact number
of the states of these Landau levels and
you can see that very easily you take
the number of electrons per level which
is EB over H then if I want to 3/4 of
these levels this is filled then it's
just I times D you put this into the
equation that I showed you earlier that
Edwin Hall derived already in the last
century and you get the result H divided
by ie squared so it's really truly it's
there's a big part here and this took
ingenious people to figure out
because what you assume in there is that
the number that the number of electrons
a certain sense is quantized and that
the system is ideal you do it here but
it's never like this the number of
electrons is fixed once and for all and
you never you never have an accept
number you have never have an exact
number of land or levels occupied except
for singular points so all this is is
that the long right this is my whole
line here along the magnetic field line
there's a few discrete points but when I
go up this resistance is exactly this
number but it doesn't say that there's
any plateau so I wouldn't even know
where they are so this is a bit of a
fake during this way but all I cannot go
much deeper into it what it tells you is
that this connection between the
quantization of the whole resistance and
the two-dimensional system a
two-dimensional Ektron system has
something to do with filling up exact
numbers of Landau levels and this big
pot here has to do with localization in
in two dimensions there's actually an
important aspect if you had an ideal two
dimension system you would not see the
quantum Hall effect
it requires dirt in order to see it I
think it's this sort of totally
counterintuitive you need dirt you need
impurities you need localization of
electrons in there in order to see it in
fact the guy that figured it out it's
going to give a talk sometime today this
is the I will not go through this
argument of course but the the bottom
line of Bob's argument one way of Lee at
least of looking at it is that our XY is
resistant you can actually regard it
which is this number you can actually
regard as a ratio of flux of magnetic
flux quantum to the electronic charge so
the ratio of flux quantum to electronic
charge and therefore you can look at
this at the quantum Hall effect if you
turn this argument around as being a
measure of e so that is a measure a very
accurate measurement of the electronic
charge which is then the flux quantum
divided by whatever you measure and then
this is an integer and the energy always
know whether it's one two
for you cannot be that far off so it is
one way of looking at the intricate
quantum artifact that is a very accurate
measurement of the electronic charge the
other aspect that is I always found
perplexing is that you measure something
to an accuracy of a few part few parts
ten to the eighth in a sample that looks
as terrible as that one this is about
three millimeters wide paps 15
millimeter long this is indium here that
is put on and diffused in in order to
make contact the black part is actually
the surface of the semiconductor which
is really shiny this space these parts
have been scratched away with an
ultrasonic scratcher really a very
intrusive method and those are gold
wires running off here this is a sample
that was made by Dan Tsui I would have
done a much nicer job but I'm sure that
my context wouldn't have worked
Dan's worked and in fact that's the
sample in which we discovered the
fraction quantum Hall effect so in in
terms of the integral quantum Hall
effect already it is it is always so
amazing that in a independent GMO
geometry any pend of how you put your
contacts on you measure something a
quantity to a few parts 10 to the 8 and
of course this is the essence of a
standard that it does not depend on the
in this case on the geometry at all you
can even make a round sample with all
contexts on the edges as long as you do
that you also measure it this is a
picture that's probably going to bring
some emotions up in some of the people
that are sitting here in the audience
certainly Larry I would think this is I
don't know which cell it is but Larry
can tell us which cell is it like what's
downstairs someplace yeah I think so
this is a 23 Tesla I suppose picture
that was shot much later
delusion refrigerator that's the fridge
this is the can for around it this is a
pumping system a person is about as big
as this pumping system and we went with
samples to the magnet lab and did
experiments with in high magnetic fields
and later on then with a dilution
refrigerator this is about 10 years
later I would think but still
when the princess bitter national magnet
leaf that was in in in up here well it
still has up he only was out the
national it was Dan and then and I were
coming up here for several years to do
experiments and it's something we were
typically getting up on Sunday morning
driving up here having a long for our
chats depending on who was driving was
either three or four hours four or five
I should say I think we're not that fast
and we had this brand new sample form
from art Gossett we're doing experiments
down in whatever cell I don't know which
stuff that was working on silicon
MOSFETs actually Dan had invited me to
come up with him he was there already
since quite a while doing experiments on
silicon and then with his new sample we
started working together on this
modulation dope systems so here's the
result of October 6 1981 this is the
hall resistance there's a magnetic field
just what Edwin Hall would have done and
there's a very nice straight line this
is an offset here so they get it still
on the chart recorder paper
it's an old technology to take data you
take a pen and pull it over a piece of
paper and then you look at the trace and
that's what your data is like ah there
is actually this is my handwriting here
this says laser upstairs you see these
spikes here there was a I don't know
which place and it was a powerful laser
upstairs and wherever they yanked it we
got a big signal down there so this is
from the laser upstairs just had to make
sure that this was not physics but just
a third effect but otherwise it's just a
nice straight line just there's Edwin
Hall would have said but they're already
deviations coming up here and these
deviations are from the integral quantum
Hall effect we knew exactly where they
were where they had to be then you so
the the top line is basically a
repetition of this taking at four
degrees and when we pumped lower to
lower temperatures indeed these
structures became nice flat Hall
plateaus and that was the last whole
plateau on the second-last Hall plateau
everything all the world was in order
but he got out of out of order up here
what you see up here is that at a
magnetic field that is about three times
as high as this one remember this is the
last hole plateaued this is last time
the Fermi energy can between can be
between two Landor levels from then on
it's always in the lowest Lander level
so there was nothing expected out here
actually I should say the reason we
looked at these things was because the
answer e at the time wanted to look at
the weakness lattice and he had done
that already in silicon and we thought
well let's look at these materials and
see where the weak unless the regional
lattices when the electron condensed
into a regular array of electrons a
hexagonal array or triangular lattice
triangular lattice I should say it's not
exactly triangular lattice of electrons
that become immobilized and they form a
nice two dimensional lattice this was a
prediction back then they are now some
indications over the years that
something like that indeed exists and
and that's what we were looking for
and what we saw is this plateau there
well it's not a plateau yet but it's
sort of a inflection point and we got
all excited about it but of course it
could be all sort of things
I mean samples resistance is very often
shut up or the shut down but this one
looked sort of clean up here but then it
developed this thing which just looks
like the integral quantum Hall effect
that a higher temperatures but at a
different point and we were standing
there down in whatever sulphur and in
about 15 seconds then did the following
and I always told us because I think
it's just wonderful and tells you a lot
about dance we he took this into his
finger the distance from here to here
and he counted off how often how often
account could counted off until he got
to this magnetic field so it was one two
three and he said one two three quarks
right and we both had a very good
chuckle about it because it was so
humorous that of course quartz that
causes our elementary particles that
with which a charge of 136 associated
and of course we're not doing elementary
particle physics the highest voltage we
have applied in our systems about 10
milli electron volts so we're not this
is a small M this is not a capital m and
it's certainly not a G so it was a good
joke
but at the same time he was dead right
because that it had something to do with
the charge of 1/3 really turned out to
be correct and that's just shows the
tremendous insight that of then so this
is then this is the argument written out
if you take bah blah fiends argument at
the time which is that the electronic
charge of whatever you measure is just
the flux want to divide it by this and
you take it seriously that's what you
get out just put the numbers in and this
is just this one two three it's one
third of an electronic charge somehow
involved if you take it literally so
cause at the time it wasn't clear
whether it was really a step or not
after all it was only a slight
inflection was only an inflection here
so the question was whether it was a
step or not and we have to look closely
whether it actually was a step you see
this is here this is not a step I often
show I often show this viewgraph
and I do it nowadays on different
continents this is the only one that can
laugh about it you go to Europe they
just there's just dead silence they
don't get this job and you know why not
this country is run by lawyers so going
to lower temperatures what was an
inflection point really became pretty
nice plateau and I always says a few
parts in ten to the four that this was
at one third and it was quantized to
about three times HOV thurso H over 130
squared I should probably put it and
simultaneously the resistance the
megiddo resistance actually developed a
deep minimum which wasn't going yet all
the way down but it looked like it as a
function of temperature was going down
another picture of the time a little bit
later down that was now around the
hybrid magnet is this one this was taken
in February 16 1984 about three years
later but the only one that I got and
those are the people that are working
with us this is Albert Chang this is
peter berkland Gregg Bob injure dance
and myself here holding up a sign 85
million Calvin 250 AD killer girls
Peter Bertrand was the guy that
developed this and built this dilution
refrigerator that's sitting down here
and there's a post Organic grad student
action MIT grad student that Peter wolf
told us about Peter said I got a good
grad student he want someone and we said
sure and Greg just became a terrific
collaborator
he's nowadays director of the magnet lab
at at Los Alamos there's one section
that's in Los Alamos and Greg is running
this man so he's still sticking to
magnets like most of us we were fell in
love with magnets can I get away from
them must have something to do with the
attractive force and so it became it
very quickly became clear that different
from the integral quantum Hall effect
this you have seen all this so I'm not
going to go through it that was the
argument that the fraction quantum Hall
effect is not a single particle effect
it does not come about from the
interaction between individual from the
sorry from the quantization of in the
individual electrons in the presence of
an electric magnetic field in the
semiconductor but it had to do with
interaction between electrons it must
come from this because all of the all of
the the steps that come about from
individual qualification of individual
electrons were all expressed in the
integer quantum Hall effect already
there shouldn't be anything else and
they were I think the smartest and
brightest of the theorists were trying
to figure it out for quite a while and
this year's Bob
and is there's nothing yet how about
unit so with an apple from hell about to
drop onto him and of course you're gonna
hear more about it but this is what he
came up with this is his wavefunction
and I'm always I always expressed that
it's it's I find this a an immense
achievement that the behavior of some 10
to the 11 electrons you can describe
everything with an equation that has
just about 15 pitches and then 15
letters in them this is Pablo Flint's
wavefunction he's going to tell us more
about it but this is a solution is this
is within quantum mechanics everything
we can know about it including all the
interactions between the electrons Bob
will modify that I suppose but let me
tell you about the fraction quantum Hall
effect and its origin from a slightly
different point of view than we that we
have developed over the when I say we
the theorists have and I'm just a a few
poor interpretation of the theorists of
the theorists work one way of looking at
the fraction quantum Hall effect
nowadays is from the point of view of
the attachment of magnetic flux to the
electrons which is driven by electron
electron interaction the electrons try
to be at the position where there's no
other electron they have to do that for
Pauli principle reasons but the more you
get the other electrons away from you
the better is for coulumb reason because
of the Coulomb interaction with the
other electrons so them so since the
wave function have zero as many particle
may function there's also zeros they try
to attract as many zeros of the wave
function onto them is advantageous in
terms of energy and one way of
describing that is in terms of what's
called two in Simon's flux it's similar
as if you had attached to the electrons
a magnetic flux this I won't go any
further into this it takes theories to
do it and certainly much more time but
then the particle statistics is actually
changing if you take two electrons you
change
summer ants and their fermions the
wavefunction gets a minus 1 in front so
their fermions if you take two electrons
with a vortex attach wealth with it
Cho and Simon's flux let's just call a
magnetic flux attached to them you get
you exchanged them you get also this
minus sign but because there's a
magnetic field and you move the
electrons around the magnetic field
that's stuck to the other electron it
gives gets an additional phase change
and therefore the minus one is
multiplied by another minus one so it's
a plus one if you stick to on it it
becomes a minus one again if you take
three it becomes a plus one so these
behave like fermions these behave like
bosons these behave like fermions these
behave they're fun in fact whenever M is
odd it looks like a four boson and
whenever M is even it looks like a
fermion and there's a long list of
people not and I couldn't list everybody
on he has a long list of people that
over time have developed this picture so
there's a way which I call here another
way because I don't have the time to
show you the the and Bob is gonna speak
later anyway so one way of looking at
the fractional quantum Hall effect at
one third then is to take electrons
imagine this reflux quanta attached to
them by virtue of the electron-electron
interaction which forces them to have
zeros on the wavefunction but just look
at this SB magnetic flux attached to
them then I look at these particles as
new particles which are no longer
fermions but bosons now and these new
particles in our green little spheres
rather than red little spheres with
three arrows on them so I have now a
system of green little balls and the red
balls plus plus flux quanta have been
transformed into these green balls and
they are now bosons rather than
electrons in a magnetic field actually
they become bosons in no magnetic field
because all of the magnetic field has
been sucked in by there by the electrons
that attach to the electrons they don't
see the magnetic field anymore this is
sort of a jump that I'm making you have
to really think more deeply about it
particularly since I'm saying it's true
and Simon flux not real flux they're
deep issues down there but just for the
for the purpose of this talk we take the
electron with reflux quanta attached to
them and make out of them what's now
called composite bosons in the absence
of magnetic field
then you have a system a new system of
composite bosons where the magnetic flux
has disappeared and this system then is
at zero magnetic field and bosons
condensed into a Bose condensate
superficially certainly and indeed
that's one of the way you can look at
the one third state that you do this
take electrons put flux wanna make new
particles and bosons in zero magnetic
field and they condense into a Bose
condensate and that's what the one third
state is so you can look at it as a post
compensation of composite bosons this is
actually historically backwards but it's
pedagogically a little bit easier to do
it this way now that's the one third
state how about all these other states
and there's a slew of them the one third
state was just the first and then there
are tons of other state that came about
and here I show you what is the magneto
resistance which looks like the
derivative because it's more impressive
and I apologize actually for the picture
because it's old by now in the meantime
there's probably five six Moore's
elations here so there's one thirty to
fifty three sevens four nines five
eleven six thirteen seven whatever up to
twenty one so see all this other fright
this the integral to interject wantem
Hall effect are these deep minima here
all the rest is fractions it's not just
the one third is it just a slew of
things or fractions this is a list of
fractions that have been seen we can
argue about to what degree we trust each
of these fractions but this is just my
way of writing it down I say this one is
okay and I think actually recently we
just have seen something it looks like
six 23rd so so it's up here you see it's
slew of fractions not just one third was
just the first one to be discovered so
what's the origin of this case so it
makes it a little bit busy that's
suddenly all of this fraction is a
little bit like these chaps here there's
a guy reading the music down here and he
say gee look at all these little black
dots that's totally confusing what's
happening there
the first thing actually that when I was
looking into and it's is this state at
1/2 C there's something at 1/2 it
doesn't look at all like this other
fraction that has this nice minima the
1/2 state is a broad little thing it
doesn't do much as a function of
temperature
this is a low temperature 100 million
Kelvin 25 million Kelvin pads it doesn't
do much it just sits there and the one
half state was for long for a long time
a miracle sort of what what this thing
is all about but then one had a
description of it and the people that
are that are most responsible for though
actually these these these these few
here but then also Jen androgyne who
actually again it's historically back
once I get to it so in the same vein of
what I told you about electrons flux
quand on to it you can then look at the
1/2 state where there's only two flux
squandered per electron you attach those
to it and as I told you earlier now they
look like fermions again but they look
like fermions without a magnetic field
all the magnetic fluxes on the electrons
and therefore you get now pink particles
pink particles that behave like fermions
but in the absence of a magnetic field
and therefore the magnetic field has
been eaten up the electrons are moving
around just like in zero magnetic field
but they're fermions and not but they're
fermions they remain fermions in spite
of the fact that two flux won't have
attached to that have been attached to
them okay just because actually and we
know what is what a system was that is
fermions in zero magnetic field does it
fills up a Fermi surface that is exactly
actually what was found an expert was
predicted first but then was found
experimentally in various experiments by
Bob Laughlin as what I'm saying Bob with
it for fluffly just become an
experimentalist what you always wanted
became being life so I made you one this
this is just a caricaturist it's just a
cartoon of it this is so you find it in
k-space
a circle like that the Fermi the Fermi
edge and you can you can measure this
never mind the fact of to in fact this
fact this difference of a fact of to
actually squared of two was an important
aspect of that yes this really looks
like it so this was found that the
electrons at 1/2 form of new Fermi
surface just like in zero magnetic field
and then you okay so we have only 1/2 so
what are all the other fractions and all
the other fraction that one can look at
in this way and that's really
historically so
of the starting point of it but for this
talk better to do this way you remember
this viewgraph that was one of the very
first view grass I've showed you just
integral quantum Hall effect
quantization this is the 2d surface
quantized Hall Lando levels etc and then
one thinks of all these other states in
a way that is analogous to the fraction
quantum Hall state sorry to the integer
quantum Hall state C the integer quantum
Hall state is down here and you get
these oscillations from the integer Hall
effect now we have another zero of
magnetic field so to say out here at 1/2
well the magnetic field has been eaten
up and if I slightly change the magnetic
field then I get a a residual magnetic
field and this particles here that sees
zero magnetic field is exactly 1/2 C a
finite magnetic field if you get a
little bit off and then they develop
Landau levels just like the electrons
developed Landau levels down here these
new particles composite fermions
developed Lando levels by themselves and
these Lando levels of the composite
fermions become the fractional quantum
Hall States
so you can look at the fraction quantum
Hall effect also as the integral quantum
Hall effect but not of regular electrons
but of composite fermions and there's a
very nice nice symmetry this is just the
same the same plot only once in red and
once in in black and if I pull this over
here where the one put them on half on
top of the zero then you see that the
the black zero minima which are from the
fraction quantum Hall effect and the red
minima which were from the Indigo
quantum Hall effect was just on top of
each other so we should have seen this
access experimentally but it was really
the theorists that we're pushing that
down our throat I suppose I have about
two minutes is this correct okay so this
picture is now confirmed in many ways
there have been experiments done on the
on these fractional states that then let
you extrapolate back to some kind of a
mass around 1/2 there's a lot of
questions still associated what's
happening exactly were at 1/2 what is
the mass what
it really mean what what kind of
phenomena do you see you there exactly
what what else could you see is it a
real Fermi system or not these are all
things that are that have been there and
still experiments being done on it but
the concept of a composite firm you and
composite boson is really something that
is that it has become very important in
the fraction quantum Hall effect the
spin of the electron has also been has
also come back in and became a very
important tool to measure some of the
energy gaps I don't have time to get
into it we can actually associate a mass
with these composite fermions we can
associate if a defect there is a
composite fermions all this has been
done over the past few years let me show
you just one other state that is of
great interest nowadays and that's a
state out here at 5 1/2 never mind how I
get to this this is the 1/2 this is a 3f
this guy is called five half it
basically means for every 5 flux quantum
you get two electrons and this state
looks sort of like this one but when you
cool this day looks sort of like this
one when you cool it down it doesn't
this is the newest experiments on that
when you cool the five half stay down
sorry it's a bit busy it goes to zero
and he gets a plateau now this is a half
state so it has an even denominator so
it should be a firm young and fermions
do not show a fraction quantum Hall
effect composite freshmen do not show a
fractional quantum Hall effect but they
show a Fermi surface this one shows a
fractional quantum Hall effect was
discovered in 87 I think populated at
all and that was a big surprise an even
denominator became a fraction quantum
Hall effect how come we still don't know
well let me actually point out this is
this is the lowest temperature ever have
cooled down an electron system these
data were just taken at the magnet lab
in Tala not Sur not a lousy Gainesville
where they have very low temperatures
Milica microkelvin for that matter we
use it only down to millikelvin in high
magnetic fields this is not that high
actually there's only 3.7 Tesla but we
were able to cool the electron system
down to 4 milli Kelvin which is a real
achievement the electrons not the
lattices the
temperature by by various trick that's
the people at the Gainesville jeong-ja
and then together with our student down
there way Penn developed that really let
us do this now the speculation the
speculation and it still is a
speculation of all although the
theorists tell us more and more that
they're very convinced about this and
they even tell us that our data
supported I don't understand that
argument yet is that what's happening is
just like at one-half the electrons
actually do form fermions they take an
electron put to flux contour onto it and
they're fermions so now we are be equal
to zero with new fermions called
composite fermions but then they
discover that they can actually mutually
attract pair vise this is an interaction
in real space but in fact the wave
functions that you can write down for it
it's called a [ __ ] I'm Way out of my
league here but it's called the puff Ian
but it's similar it looks similar to a
BCS wavefunction with an L equal to one
and there but there's an interaction in
there and they form pairs and these
pairs sort of in for analogy with Cooper
pairs if you think of it they can
condense they form a new quantum liquid
now so you form first fermions then you
have an interaction which is just all
Coulomb interaction and they form pairs
and these pairs then open up a new gap
which is something like a
superconducting gap so in a sense they
form a new kind of superconductor made
out of composite fermions and that's
what you see in the in the experiment
let me let me leave it at that their
various other experiments that that are
very other parts of the magnetic field
scale there's there nowadays
anisotropies that are being discovered
in high magnetic fields they're they
call stripe phases there's the question
for example how many electrons are
required and see in order to see the
fraction quantum Hall effect obviously
one is not good enough I say obviously
but this is an important part one is not
good enough it's in many particle effect
and some people like ray and others are
looking whether 3 is enough or five is
enough what do you need 10 in order to
see you there's a weakness solid out
there where electrons are supposed to
condense into a solid of electrons
and that one there are indications for
it there are things called skirm yawns
which has many particle spin systems
that are playing a role so they this
this field is a life and well to say the
least in fact I believe the five half
state if we really can pin it down that
if this kind of a state is really
opening up a whole new universe of
experiments that can be done let me let
me show you my last view graph and that
is sort of where we going this is the
data or the result that Edwin Hall gave
us about a hundred years ago magnetic
field all effects straight line so this
is just a standard Hall effect and
clouds from litsen came along and told
us that this is not so there's actually
you see this is a used you graph I
better fix it up there's these big steps
in here this is the integral quantum
Hall effect and then then and I was so
lucky to discover the one third state so
suddenly there were more steps here and
then the five step five something came
along and the seven and eleven and the
third teens and the 17s and the 23 and
as we keep going we're going to end up
with that which is a perfectly straight
line only what you don't see is that
they're infinitely many steps along here
it's called a devil's staircase devil
for obvious reasons and there's going to
be fractions all over the place so
eventually we're going to end up just
like Edwin horn is gonna tell us I told
you so so let me just show you this view
graph here was just probably the most
important all of this wasn't I only
changed pump oil course then who's gonna
talk long friend and collaborator and
really my mentor in many ways lots of
collaborators postdocs students at Bell
Labs that have worked on that on that on
the fractional quantum Hall effect and
then there is particularly the people
that are the crystal growers that are
here pointed out in all important ones
here in red art Gossett in a Willie
Whitman and then also Loren Pfeiffer and
Ken West who are growing the samples
nowadays
so it was these people working on the
fraction quantum Hall effect that really
brought it all about I always feel that
then and I we were so lucky to discover
it's a little bit like archaeology we
discovered the first tile sticking out
from a roof out of the sand and then it
was all these terrific people that
continued the work and really were
cleaning up the hole not cleaning up
actually discovering the whole building
which finally were made us to receive
the Nobel Prize for it I feel like the
luckiest person in the world having been
able to work with such terrific people
and being part of of this endeavor so in
a sense I think I owe a lot of not in a
sense I do owe a lot of gratitude to all
of these people that have brought it
about I feel that I was only one of the
lucky ones that was just there at the
right time at the right place thanks
very much
[Applause]
and of course the right place at the
time was sort of one one street down the
road
thanks for the full overview you don't
get away so soon are the questions don't
want to cut into dents mark no yes of
course no no no nope no doubt we see the
fraction quantum Hall effect now at
point eight kilo Gauss something like
this right so this is exaggerated but
there's a few key lookouts oh yes of
course today but at this time no this
sample is required this sample which was
90,000 mobility and a field of whatever
it was 19 Tesla or something like that
where this is where the inflection was
to see it and any lower than that it
wouldn't have happened nowadays we have
superconducting magnets that go that
high at that point superconducting
magnet where typically a Tesla so one
would not have seen it yes at the point
it required this sample and this
magnetic and this magnetic field a few
years later if actually it had been
pursued any further maybe people would
have said well forgetting up modulation
doping does it look interesting but a
few years later you could do it at home
meaning in a superconducting magnet but
not at the time Oh blah
by what h/h they know this is edge
states are always the next generation
right I mean you first have to get the
bulk let me not call it balk you first
have to get whatever we are doing the
trivial stuff right before you look into
the edge states it's a tunneling into
the edge that is a difficult problem
right you know I mean it's still there's
lots of question about what do you
really see when you chiral systems etc
so we don't I don't have anything maybe
Dan is gonna tell you something but
don't think no we don't have anything on
the on the edge now the other thing to
differentiate the two states is whether
it's been polarized on polarized and
that's already a difficult one that's
the experiment that we want to do since
a year but it's so hard to turn a sample
at four million electron temperature
down and a high magnetic field and see
whether one sees the lifting of the spin
degeneracy that I think is the trivial
experiment although it's very hard and
then comes the edge why do they call the
5s have stayed a superconductor when the
longitudinal conductance doesn't goes to
zero so is that just you know why okay I
mean it's it's the analogy with
superconductivity is is is a long one
there's lots of things that are
different but since it looks like it has
sort of character of the PCs
wavefunction in there so you can look at
it as being superconductivity
but then of course everything else is
different so don't catch me at my weak
points okay
Peter yes
I don't think so I don't think so I'm
but I mean there is a description of of
these states here a theoretical
description I think that all the
connections are not yet made in fact it
was theoretically predicted that they
were stripe phases let's also keep in
mind there's a prediction of stripe
phases or something Audrey and then
their experiments are shown anisotropy
so far the connection that the
anisotropy is due to stripe phases had
not really been made we just think this
is the area where this and whether it's
anisotropy this is the area where there
should be striped face it probably
that's what it is one doesn't really
know that what has been discovered is in
our satrapy but it's probably striped
phases from the front point of theory I
think there we got the experts in here
what okay this is one with Patrick
so was it back at this time in the
magnet lab when you came up with horse
first law but I teach my students all
the time the crummiest sample the
crummiest looking samples always talk
best yeah I guess I learned this from
Dan in many ways okay for no more
questions let's thank Horst again it's a
real pleasure to welcome den Suri to MIT
then soon after he got his PhD from
Chicago with then went to Bell Labs
where he spent about 15 years before we
went to a Princeton University as a
professor in the electrical engineering
department I got to know Dan in the 70s
when we're both in Bell Labs and as some
of you might know especially that in
those days Bell Labs was known for
having a bunch of very aggressive people
around well there are a few exceptions
to this to this rule and then it's one
of them but then there may not be the
one
we'll walk so fastest or talks the
fastest but when it comes to murder that
count it doesn't take long to figure out
that he's usually when it gets there
first I had experience for example in
the in the late 70s when lot of us were
doing work on the localization week
localization facts and disorder effects
and so on
dan was really very quick he instantly
understood the importance of what's
going on understood the theory and he
realized immediately that the MOSFET
system is the ideal system to to study
these these new theories because he can
control the electron density and
everything else so within a matter of a
month or two he and David Bishop came
came up with the experiment that
definitely experiment that that showed
all these weak localization effects and
so on and of course the next great
achievement was the fractional quantum
Hall effect that we'll hear about
since the time I came to MIT in 82 and
one of the great pleasures is to have
periodic visits from from Dan when he
comes to do experiments at the
imaginable happened every time he would
come and he would show me all these new
data that he that he found that he's
excited about that he wants understand
but every time I talked to Dan I always
come away with the impression that he's
someone who is really fascinated by
nature by what he's doing he loves being
at the frontier and exploring this new
world and he he's someone who really
wants to understand what he's studying
and to him you know being getting credit
or being the first or getting honor
seems to be secondary these are things
that would come naturally for him he
science is really what drives him and so
it's wonderful that this great honor has
come to someone who really does not seek
it and so I present to you Dan
[Applause]
yes
Thank You Patrick it is an honor and
always a pleasure to be back on MIT
campus I think a horse Prada will say
well I enjoyed it so much even spent the
first my first sabbatical in a mango
laughs in the Francis Victrola Oh what
what I want to do for the talk is to
take this opportunity to have a closer
look of some the long-standing problems
as characterized by some the questions
some of the questions and comments we
use to hear very often so more
specifically what I'm going to do is I
can you give you a very brief
superficial overview basically relating
the overall the other even denominator
fractions which horst already touched
upon but before I go into that any
detail into that those experiments I'm
you know spend some time how you say
counting experiment into the sample
edges and I don't think I'll or Richard
and I thought I'll also go so something
microwave absorption experiments in the
very small fresh no limit where the
system the electrons are insulating our
true insulators and it's a if you like
it's a believed it well it is the
putative winner crystal regime but I
probably will not have time to go into
that so this is what I would like to do
let me I have this view graph here just
to remind me to say that this in our
modern-day electronics world and most II
device functions are performed by these
two-dimensional electrons which confined
to move along the interface of two
different semiconductors or
semiconductor and and arcs and insulate
but the only point I want to make here
is
under normal and be these electrons
behaves as just ordinary gas of
two-dimensional particles the strange or
the extraordinary physics which he Horst
have has shown us is becomes dominant or
very apparent when you take a system to
at low temperatures exposed to high
magnetic field and when the system
actually is clean it's a clean
two-dimensional system that's the point
but they the other point I want to make
is really that the only reason I want to
show that you graph before actually let
me put it back in the magnetic field the
energy or the so-called landau contas
agen quantizes the energy spectrum into
the screen levels if you like they're
massively degenerate discrete levels and
these levels are called Landau levels
and the point I want to make here is
mainly the terminology I want to keep
straight the Landau level index this big
end
this usually integers 0 1 2 3 large
numbers you know whatever numbers so if
you want you take the electron spin into
account each Landau level the composer
O'Hara has to spin levels that's the
only point I want to make because we
need to keep that in mind to look at
some of the data and some detail ok you
we have ready
it's hurt from the horse talk that in
the so called fresh and O'Connell
holliford regime correlation is
everything and the for the the art
denominator freshness what we know the
system is going into a so-called whole
liquids at the our denominator no more
liquids we have these fresh in those
states you have seen but that also we
have seen there is they actually even
denominator freshest correlation favors
normal metal like Fermi sea of composite
particles or the composite fermions and
this is the case for the lowest Landau
level if you like the N equal to zero
Landau level and this is the data
actually from very recent sample Loren
Pfeiffer macam West grown grown out in
September and the data was taken by way
pine was a greater student horse died
supervised and the what you notice here
the filling factor to somewhere here and
down so this is for the an equal to zero
Landau level so all the so that we to
spin-spin splitting up down here
somewhere and have the spin down okay
for so in this level
indeed the campus fermium is what the
ground stay for the even d-dimer fresh
census indicated here and for example
the one-half you have already heard from
you know horror story to show to you
except in this sample
because the profession of the 2d
electron system this why now bicycle
horses to whatever 20 that there are 21
or 20 or whatever and here is similarly
for one force and the main thing is for
the even a fraction where the campus of
fermium is the ground state the
structure is essentially featureless and
is flanked by two series in this case
the P over 4p plus minus one series of
fresh and O'Connell Hall States and here
the P over 2 P plus minus one series of
rational Hall States and similarly for
the 3/4 and three half so for the N
equal to zero Landau level indeed the RT
now means refreshments are the freshman
of quantum Hall liquids the even
denominator freshens are these composite
fermions States for the higher Landau
level that's what I want to show here
and that apparently is not the case the
data looks very different
again here is the lowest Landau level
and equal to 0 you see the even anomeric
freshen is essentially featureless just
fresh and open are all states come
converges on to this the fresher the
Kalahasti has a steam minimum and just
converges into this even compasso fermi
on the firm ground state the capacity
for me I'm gas states essentially
featureless well when you go to the next
Landau level and you could one level
that's for the seven half and five half
and you have the minimum which is very
similar to the
upon Mahalo states and also these
structures you know the flanks on the
sides those are indeed the fresh and
open or halt states okay now when you go
to the the next higher letter level the
index is an equal to 2 and the you see
actually see a large spikes at 9 half 11
half and similar for the next level in
you go to 3:13 have fit 15 1/2 this
actually becomes have large Peaks but
more importantly whether they're a peak
or a minimum or a very deep minimum
depends on how you do the measurement
depend on the measurement the current is
measured at what direction the blacks
measured along this direction defined as
X direction and the other one is the y
direction so this is basically what well
what I'm going to do so I'll come back
I'll come back to show you more data
look at these higher Landau level and
equal to 1 and equal to 2 and pick in
particular just pick out the 5 half and
nine half to go through the experiment
in some detail but before I do that I
want to address basically the other
comments you have seen is above the edge
States
Halperin and one-celled on one product
sitting somewhere in the audience I know
we're the first told us how to think
about these the sample ages how to think
about the edge States in case of the
integer on a Hall effect is quite easy
to visualize or to picture them and
that's what is illustrated on this
viewgraph if this is the bulk material
in a strong magnetic field we look at
the one electron energy levels there are
just these Landau levels separated by an
energy gap which is the cyclotron energy
now when I go to the surface approaching
the surface sample surface then when the
electron orbiting the magnet of you they
let how feels the surface potential or
the surface feel then the changes
increases the electron energy so I would
my Landau level what I have to be drawn
in this way so now if I add the integer
part of all states so my Fermi level is
somewhere between these two levels below
are all filled top or my n below and
it's all filled my n plus one is all
empty then of crisps inside the sample
in the bulk is an insulator escaped
well one come to the surface there is
state right at the Fermi level and these
states or if you like the electrons say
in these states are one they consider
one dimensional electron system and you
know this becomes more clear on the next
view graph it's in a real space
this is how it would look this of course
you would Ryder will recognize this
progress of graduate students thesis who
else would do this need to think this is
taken from that grease and ceases as a
matter fighter data I'm going to show
you are all from from him is D so Eddie
in the bulk in the quantum Hall effect
the levels you know all these site from
orbit all occupied and the next higher
energy level ones are empty it's not
shown here but come to the edges the
edge states are just the so call in
metaphysics in the 60s were call them
the skipping orbits these are the
skipping orbits and because the magnetic
field they all skip in one direction and
the the language to proper length to
describe the saying a fancier language
their motion of Cairo and this is for
the integer case and there has been a
lot of experiment give evidence to this
for the Fresnel case it's a what you
would have for the freshener case of
course again the bulk in the bulb will
be kept the charge of excitation will
get up and the edges electrons the edges
will comes to again a one dimensional
electron system but it's interacting
system and it's well known that for
one-dimensional interacting electron
system and it's you know the ground
states it's a liquid and usually it's
called a large internal equipment again
because the magnetic field is the cairo
is called a tire or a large internal
equipment and main characteristic
terrifies lines into liquid yes it has
phone unlike
excitation spectrum so the density of
states at the Fermi level if you like
vanishes but yet given you know the two
finite energy excitation the density of
states goes over some power law
dependence
seen indicated here and this would have
direct consequences on the current due
to tunneling either into the edge or
tunneling between the edges so if you
look at the current with a tunneling
current into the edge freshener edge or
the tunneling current between the fresh
no edges this will have direct influence
toria consequences the the earlier
experiment found this is the Milliken on
bar Webb's experiment or they look at
the temperature dependence of the
tunneling current between the edges
using a point contact geometry but what
I'll do basically showing the data made
Grayson took my recent hat is following
the tunneling which is tunneling from
essentially normal metal into the edge
which in some sense many of you our show
you over become very clear if you just
reminisce and you know if you remember
the norm Lantos superconductor Jamison
in superconductivity okay so
so but this okay this is just repeat
what I said already so what I'm going to
show you sir the experiment mayor
Grayson my Grayson's in the data and
using the sample Lauren Pfeiffer and
Kane west chrome this is the edge cliff
it overgrows reassuring mentioned
earlier the structure at the end is you
have the two-dimensional electron system
on this side and the 2d electron yes
it's confined in a quantum well
indicated here then from the edge cliff
over grows at a no barriers grown which
is in this case be aluminum gallium
arsenide town of area then a very
heavily doped semiconductor electro m+
get around which is just a normal metal
electron so the experiment is to inject
or tau no electrons into the fresh and
o'connell whole system that's the
experiment and if you remember from the
normal metal supercontinent normal metal
superconductor tunnel Junction there the
classical gave a raw tunneling geometry
which your measurements are in tanana
inject electron into this internal
strongly interacting system the
one-dimensional a lot inter liquid
system and if you look at the so called
tunnel conductance derivative the IV
curve you measure directly the tunneling
conductance so the experiment is just to
measure the IV
characteristic the IV curve and this is
just another view what you have see
there this is for the one third stage
the bulk charging stations gapped and
the edge all the actions on the edge
that's the one-dimensional argent or
liquid and the experiment just basic
this measure on the IV characteristic
you expect a power law dependence and
the exponent alpha is basically Wow if
you see the right L that's basically
characterized this edge will not enter
liquid sometimes
we don't think oh I have another picture
this is just a more realistic picture
from match Grayson this is a 2d electron
layer so you can put contacts so you can
characterize the freshener wanna haul
characteristics you said characterize
your sample and here is the tunneling
the normal electro injecting into that
okay so you can look at the
the red curve is the IV characteristic
the whole reason in character risk of
the 2d lie trial and this is the wines
are applied to all this that you v this
is the 2/3 is the plateau 1 and this is
the tunneling IV and if you look at the
HD at a freshener 1/3 state you would
expect the kind of lighting to liquid
and he expect to have a chiral adding to
liquid and the IV should have you expect
the power or dependence and with an
exponent
it's expected to be actually for 3 ah
this is the first piece of data from
albert chan's early experiment and this
is right at filling factor one served we
know the bulk is capped and the edge we
expect to have the alerting juror liquid
and there is more than two decades as
the power of clear power law dependence
indicator and the power is 2.7 is
sufficiently close to the expect value
of 3
which match Grayson did is I see look at
a large number of samples on each
samples you know not only a D you know
1/3 or 2/3 also away from those that
large you know just continue the various
magnetic field very close great look at
it how do they look
and surprisingly when you mean you're
not so one-third and I think it's the
green when you're away from the wine sir
you also have the same power or
dependence and then in this wide range
from 15 Tesla to 7-tesla you all have
this power law dependence as a matter of
fire this power law this is same I hope
this is a log plot this power law
dependence will cover basically about
four decades you know you know I think a
you know range is certainly unambiguous
and the next few view graph I just flip
them very quickly it just v they made
the fit is to a theory well you can even
just you can use just a resistor network
be the same way this is the fittest
which was shaman freken's theory this is
right around one-third is fit it gets
two point eight where Albert Chan had
earlier two point seven and this is the
higher feel and the fit again there's
this is about four or five decades it's
about four point two that fit and again
you're away from the I'll just very
quickly flip to give you some sense the
fitori this is proud about three decades
or so and
look if a power-law about 2.5 and this
one probably they're narrower range but
still no it's not it's still about four
decades
if you about about four so all I just
want to mention what I want to show is
if you take all his data from the power
law dependence this the exponent is
alpha and all the data plot the mob is
is from these four samples these circles
are Elbert chains early data they
essentially all fall roughly this
straight line it's I mean the immediate
the first price of surprising is you
know the you know when Europe away from
the plateau region in the whole in the
freshman away from the fresh and
O'Connor hall states the bulk is not yet
the bulk you know has conduction but the
edge state you know the larger nuclear
picture the edge mode which are larger
liquids are still you know proper
description of it and the other one of
course this is the - the curve is the
theory from sight all levitoff and
Halperin and this discrepancy between
experiment and theory I think it still
remains a problem
the other point I want to just mention
that for the filling factor wine and a
higher in this region it's expected the
HMO the edge channels are Fermi liquid
and the exponent is just you know your
normal IV curve just expected to be one
deal
more recently Michael healthy was a post
out of Princeton look at into between
basically between one filling factor
well went to somewhere here I sorta
sploded are more data and indeed this
you know this flatten out one of course
earlier but indeed as continue but a his
sample or the sample he looked at the
data to date is basically it's not good
enough to say anything about what about
Eddie compulsive fermium crust stage
three half or the five half those
particular fillings that basically is
all I want to say in relation to town
into the edges of the fresh and quantum
Hall effect
now I would like to come back to thee
even an even denominator freshens in
higher levels levels for the Landau
index and you could 1 and higher
this is reduce data which is Santos
actually Lauren 5'4 and who can we're
screwing in I think it's 1991 this state
our lead detour so but the point I
already mentioned if I look at the 5
half there's clear minimum you know it's
very different from the 5 having very
different from what you've seen you know
1/2 or 1/4 for the composite fermions in
nature in the date but more strikingly
is when you go to nine 1/2 and be left
half which is 49 down ever index in
equal to 2 for the 9 11 13 half and you
sure very large resistance you speak
very strong resonance peak and depends
on the or in the current orientation
which direction you measure the
resistance in the 90-degree off raises
in duration it's a deep minimum and it
to in order to be able to go through the
data later more it's kind of a confusing
once I told them I'm going to feel I
want you to keep in mind two things why
nasty these lines vertical lines
indicates the easy
conduction direction in if you measure
the current in that direction that's in
this case the resistance does not have
resistance small okay perpendicular to
that direction it's a hard conduction
direction so this is a measure a
perpendicular and the hard direction is
the X direction and the easy direction
it's the y direction so that's one point
I want you to keep in mind okay
the other point is in addition to this
sharpie there are also other structures
and these structures they don't fit the
fresh Nakano whole ski you know they
don't fit this one-third or two-thirds
and when the temperature goes you know
or you lower the temperature that's
indicated here and everything
disappeared just the spike for this
current direction the spike dominates
okay and in addition to that because I
want to mention this is a you know
sample was in India almost a decade ago
with the the samples are in growing
those days are now rotated so you can
have some very in you know very density
gradient some very small in this sample
the density gradient is sort of a about
or less one less than one percent in
this direction but I think it really
look at a very carefully come
it's very convincingly this and I saw to
be the difference cannot be attributed
to this slide entity grading okay but
I'm going to show you the data on the
next view graph from Jim Eisenstein
encounter Lillian kilter those are
sample were very recent along the
rotator
no in how much no this non-uniformity
the result is essentially the same but
before I do that let me just also say
another two other point for this sample
the plane the sample plane is 100 ruin
major x-ray diffraction very carefully
the orientation is better than 0.05
degree and these edges one one know
there are cleavage edges you Cleveland
they're just essentially right out these
are the few things of animation was that
chipping was that in mind well first let
me just show you the data from which you
know are more recent samples in terms
the to the electron quality you know to
Durant system quality but the data is
essentially the same okay in one
direction it's largely the same Theory
versus minimum okay and Lilly and they
also look at the different orientations
the data you know you have seen before
is essentially the current measure along
the two different one one old
corrections where here they also H one
rotate the sample by 45 degree and you
still see somewhere nice art repeat but
it's much smaller so this experiment
actually pinned down located worthy
anisotropy directionless okay now with
this in mind now I want you to just
stared at a few foils
to go through the overall first this one
is a temperature characteristic
so do this anisotropy they basically 115
millikelvin it's isotropic sort of
hardly any difference the anisotropy
started basically about 100 millikelvin
and it becomes stronger and stronger
that's one and the other structures have
already mentioned that they don't these
they don't fit any fresh '''l all states
and this data curve here is the hole
resistance the whole resistance has
structures in this region you know
basically there is some inter the lowest
temperature I think is the solid line so
there are clear structures but so far
you know there's no we haven't been able
to identify the structures for any you
know clearly identify the physics the
mix of you graph is just a summary of
this one just plot the temperature
dependence this is for the nine have
maximum and minimum the essential I
salute they're the same isotropic about
$100 Kelvin by about sixty mother can
Kelvin the essentially saturate the
growth and this is just plot the
structure on the side it does not really
fit any fractional states on this side
which is for these two different
orientations okay for that of two
different current orientations
thus basic ready
then date and data and the features I
want to show you the application of
inflaming letter field has a very large
if that on this anisotropy that's
indicated here I probably should look at
first okay yes indicated here if I apply
a magnetic field in the I apply a magnet
of you this is the imprint field I put
apply a few in the brain of the sample
okay and this is the imprint feel if the
in brain feels applied in the difficult
can this is in the in the easy
conduction direction as the y direction
if I apply it in the easy conduction
direction it suppresses the resistance
in the heart conduction duration in the
hard duration the resistant nine have
large becomes small small very small at
the same time the easy conduction
direction the resistance getting larger
larger than getting very large if you
like this put a feel for the implants
field in the easy direction now changes
the easy conduction duration to the hard
conduction duration and the hard
conduction version changes into easy I
know it's confusing as well what's
basically hot
I'm trying to say is basically I try to
say what the data tells you tells you
this and in plain view makes the
transport along it hard makes the
transport along the implant field
duration hard if you put a large implant
field at the end of the day the easy
conduction duration is perpendicular to
the incline field that's really all I'm
gonna see right right right
there are no hysteresis and this is
consistent well in some sense once you
look at it this one would you make it at
that conclusion I think even more clear
see this of course in you put a few
already in the heart conduction
direction
so in some sense the things are already
aligned in the right direction
at the end actually you don't change
anything but in between it changes
things so at the end when you put an
implant field put a few in the plan the
implant feel Orient's the system in such
a way at the end the easy conduction
direction is perpendicular to implant
field that's the message I want you to
take away with that's really that's what
the experiments ok the gross part of the
experiment that's what it is okay now
the
the more the experiment of Chris has
much more detail you know all I'm saying
at the end so at the end if you start
out with a line in the right direction
the implant feels perpendicular the easy
hundred at the end nothing changes just
ampere to someone and if we're on to
Russian they switch easy becomes hard
hard becomes easy in between they're
definitely more than that and later in
some sense II can feel well the profit
is reasonable you put an implant for you
you know not only you do some kind of a
nice art review really the thing but you
also change you know there's a my energy
all kinds of things okay but the main
thing at this stage I want you us to you
know keep in mind aside this is just the
same thing this plot you know and I
thought rapidity you know difference of
the reasons in the truth direction
normalized by the song okay but the
message really is you put an incline for
you and that few you know forces the
system into such a condition the easy
conduction duration is perpendicular to
the magnetic field
yeah
our current understanding of it or list
it Nesta that's what you what I hear
people telling me yes this so-called
strife face the understanding of it is
to go back to the klasky and his
collaborators earlier it's paper wrong
and also around the hartree-fock
calculations for the ground state of to
the electron system in a magnetic field
what they find is he find a for landau
index bigger and equal than 2 and the a
charge a unit rational that's you stand
for a unidirectional charge density wave
state is favored over the fractional
quantum Hall state I have a sort of a
cartoon of a picture here just try to
give you some you know flavor what all
those big words mean in some sense what
it means essentially said the
possibility when you go to well you're
not half filling the system phase
separates it separates filling factor
for all states and filling factor five
whole liquids for five four and these
stripes so if I look at the 2d density
and they basically this was a density
wave was this my pure DISA T that's
really that's the only a point I try to
convey
with this ID a very recently I think
must be too late I got lazy right it's
you worse I think the McDonald Gervin
and his murder
they have calculator D and ice atropine
energy when you put an implant field and
the fine is said the in flaming of the
few tens to align the stripes
perpendicular to it so in the back to
this picture what's their finding or to
say if this stripes in this way the in
prime feel you put an implant for you at
the end of the day they imply for you
will tend to align this day and I saw
tribunal is such align the stripes
perpendicular to the implant and in that
sense in a sense well which since we
don't have a transport theory we don't
already know how to think of transport
but adjust in this phase separation here
you will say in this direction I try to
indicate these are the edges there's
four four there will be you know a lot
of four edge states and these edges
states can you know they're compressible
and the bulk are incompressible so this
certainly is the easy conducting
direction it's a longer stripe so the
magnetic field tends to make the easy in
this picture for this for this stripe
model strife face model would align it
perpendicular to the magnetic field in
that sense is consistent with the
experimental observation so qualitative
or the main features of the experiment
are the experimental data is consistent
with this stripe face picture of a
crystal relate a more qualitatively to
the experiment and also the more
detailed structures will need a need a
transport theory in particular how do
you transport charge in this kind of
model across the stripes in addition in
this in the hartree-fock model there is
also in addition to the strive fees
there's also bubble fees so you know
just what Kim won't attribute those
additional structures in the region
other than the peak you know away from
the mat in half can one attribute that
or assign there to be for example the
bubble phase I think we have to wait and
see
probably okay let me the next part let
me just mention we go back to the N
equal to one or the five half even
denominators refreshing that's a horse
as I already pointed out in his talk let
me go back to also with o basically I
want to remind you is for 1/2
you know same three half earlier we saw
quarter I sensory the composite fermions
signature essentially it's just a very
broad minimum but this is the data in
1987 was he was mentioned but if you
look at a five half this structure the
minimum is much stronger than was
expected the more detailed result the
more detail experiment was on this
viewgraph when you change the
temperature from a hundred millikelvin
to the lowest about 25 minute Calvin
this minimum Deveny
becomes very strong it looks like a you
know a certain it's not you know very
different from the composite fermions
signature
hmm one half for us we have and if when
you look at the whole resistance that's
this data here and it clearly shows
clear deviation from the classical holla
and this certainly strongly suggest the
five have yes you know or the five have
you know could be your a may be a fresh
and oh quantum Hall state the more
recent data you have seen already horse
they're shown no sir
the thirty to eat are using the
microkelvin facility in Gainesville for
certain already mentions we pine and shy
in why Adams with microkelvin lab and
the experiment here's five have clear
shows you are indeed cooling the
electron temperature so the electron
temperature is being cooled very very
clear okay
that's one point but all not to all on
that let me just mention the once you
cool the temperature below the time to
run at the lowest temperature indicated
here and there's very clear plateau and
the Platt home
quantized the quantum number five have
just essentially using the two and three
as a calibration and calibrate against
them those is quantized accurately to
better than 2 ppm the limitation is just
you know it didn't worry but they did it
just the instrument you know
instrumentation wasn't designed for
better quantization so this clearly says
the five half state is India of fresh
new quantum Hall States it's indeed
incompressible flows at the present
there are two candidates or at the
present or or I should say it was
throughout the years there are two
candidates for the ground state what is
the ground state one is the singular
state of what usually is called a halt
dein reside hollow-core type is
basically the interaction potential has
this particular hollow-core model when
is this odd okay
and the other one is the fashion stays
whenever you have so many else but
course already mentioned of the Father
which Rudy is is a p-wave pairing of the
composite fermions horse one to some
detail of the bcs type of Condit's
the early support for the experimental
support evidence or evidence not the
support from experiment in the early
days for this single estate is the total
magnetic field experiment see one way to
view the total magnetic field yes since
the electron system is two-dimensional
indicated here you can increase the
total magnetic field without changing or
put it the other way
keep the perpendicular field constant
and still increase the total magnetic
field of course the Fresnel quantum Hall
correlation the correlation give you
rise to the fractional quantum Hall
state in the polarized in the simplest
case it is actually the sum is the given
by that for a simplicity it's a
perpendicular magnetic field first
Feynman energy is related to the total
magnetosphere so by tilting the magnetic
field essentially you know keep the
perpendicular feel constant you can one
of the simplest way to view this you the
only thing or you do nothing to the
system except you're changing the Zima
energy that would be the simplest way to
view the total field so if you do if you
do that view to that way and do the
total magnetic field experiment this is
what you find this is the early earlier
data from
jim-jim Eisenstein and Bob Willa this is
a zero magnetic few a very strong
minimum at five half when you total
magnetic field I'm in a decrease
decrease well I see we increase when you
told her you increase the total for you
basically this happened a total for you
earlier for some tests when I was five
some Tesla but the perpendicular for you
is the same at this point okay it's four
point eight Tesla and by the time the
Pearl feel or the Zima energy increased
about five point seven nine is very weak
but the time more than seven Tesla for
the total field or the Zima energy then
this the five half structure disappeared
or the five half state is quenched this
in some sense was the strongest support
for the singular state but very quickly
there you know the more recent
experiment and makes this you know
certainty so there is problem who is
this it's not one is shown by this data
here from this data the five half is
still equally strong and appeared at
about twelve and a half Tesla almost
thirteen Tesla that's a very large save
on energy so that's one problem I think
that a more definite promise of this
sort of suggest maybe the singular state
there's something not right and so the
the other problem came in some sense he
came more clear become clearer more
recently
that's the totem for you experiment you
have already seen the totem for you in
relation to the nine half now it's
essentially the same experiment saying
tell Timmy experiment I just look at the
data at 5:00 half okay well if you look
at the five half in this case the
implant feels put along the heart
conduction direction the implant feel
okay the heart condition duration is for
the nine half for five half third you
know isotropic anyway so that but now
you put an implant for you once you put
it in brain field then you see they
become and isotropic and depend on what
to ration you measure eventually when
the implant feels sufficiently large so
you have so one duration becomes hard
conduction the internalization is the
easy convert this what the implant feels
in the heart conduction fresh okay now
if you put I didn't cry and feel in the
other person again it's the same thing
at the end at the end I want a few
sufficiently large and you get become
the system becomes an isotropic the five
half in the easy conduction for the ban
half easy conduction duration becomes
larger is it difficult to come down the
other direction so the main message here
on says you put an implant field now or
toady do a totally experiment but keep
on told him totally even higher but then
you find out the system the and
isotropic
so the what you have seen earlier just
the suppression of the minimum that's
the only part of the story so after you
keep on toting it's not our only
suppress the the orange disappear but if
you're in the right to write actually in
them they're measuring the right
direction you get a maximum
instead of okay that that's really the
message to the other and just you know
put these data since have all the data
so plot it out okay that's really the
that main message and some were here
okay this is the same again it's with
that this is just let me just not even
bother that's just the product and I
thought that but I want to show you this
is the data from Lilian Eisenstein from
calton its same result
let's put it here you produce a strongly
and isotropic transport on the fine when
you put a magnetic field so which what
the experiment says for this experiment
told us is that the dominating effect of
the total experiment the dominate effect
it's not the same energy the dominie
effect is the implant fear induce
anisotropy you know you see this
anisotropy energy we seen something well
I guess the heart rate for calculations
okay so the dominant effect is the in
plain view induced and I saw it's not as
a bomb so the imprint feel what it does
that destroys it destroys the five half
freshen quantum Hall effect states and
in in its place it creates a if we use
the nine halves this guy or if we
believe that I have stay is a unit
rational charge density we've stay
ground state then it creates a unit
rational charge density wave state
that's the stripe face
and the experiment you see the totem few
experiment which really every season is
a feast transition phase transition from
this favi on state or p we've paired
state of the bcs type to the strive face
and this transition is driven by when
you apply this in plane magnetic field
there's a preprint I think I have device
there are two three prints one has three
names one two I think it's the one
resilient holding the recalculation is a
finite number a certain number of
electron calculation their calculation
sort of kind of shows that for the
spin-polarized system and essentially
the 5e on state energy and strive facing
energy are very close together so they
would say if you you know can change the
interaction potential some more your
honor it's very easy to change it from
one to the other
okay that's right okay I think my time
stopped
I have already said I want to see
anything okay let me just say three this
these few words okay what basically I
was gonna
I was gonna say this the picture that
has emerged from a recent experiment is
that the states of a clean I sort of
emphasize the Korean two dimensional
electron system is magnetic field at
Fresno feelings for the Landau levels 1
& 0 means the first four if you count
the spin levels for land on a floor
filling factor new bigger than roughly
bigger than 1 6 you have a fresh new
quantum Hall the quiz the RT Dominator
of fractions and the given denominator
fractions you have this composite
fermium guess if a composite for a meal
for me look with it for the lowest in
the lowest line now live case for n you
could want that for 5 half what you have
you know very likely I think here so
this P we've paired composite Fermi on
the quiz then for n bigger than to the
higher Landau levels
itapira sizing the true data sort of
indicates the hartree-fock wrong states
as a lower energy than the freshmen
countable States I not time to say
anything about the Wigner crystal but
it's believed in the clean system for
the filling factor less than 1/6
there's the Wagner crystal stay down but
in real life of course
the physical phenomena we see are always
interplay the results of interplay
between disorder and the
electron-electron interaction that turns
out in this winter crystal case if for
in their regime the disorder becomes
very important and disorder the present
certain is one of the most difficult
problem and we really don't know how to
or characterize I better stop
well thank thank you Dan for a very
current update on this exciting story
that obviously is still ongoing that
there may be time for just a quick
question from the audience okay since we
are running late maybe we should just
move on next and Lex thank Dan again
[Applause]
so now I'm going to give John Joe
andopolis the joy of introducing Bob
Laughlin thank you Mark
it is indeed with the particular
pleasure and in pride that I introduce
our next speaker
Bob Laughlin as I'm sure many of you
know Bob's talents is his brilliance and
creativity as a as a as a theorist have
by now become legendary but what you may
not know is that some of these talent
talents actually overflow into other
areas such as music and art it turns out
that Bob is an accomplished pianist he
is also a composer composer of classical
music he's written for piano concertos
he's also a skillful sketch artist and a
very clever cartoonist you can see you
can find some of his work on the web on
his on his home page actually some of my
favorite cartoons are jibes at the
National Science Foundation which Bob
calls the National sounds foundation and
in the first two talks we saw that some
very beautiful and pioneering
experiments led to the discovery of a
new two-dimensional electron gas
electron system with some very unusual
properties and of course now the
question was how can one account for
these experiments how can one understand
what the nature of this system is now
interestingly historically fascination
with two-dimensional fluids actually
dates back to antiquity the first
written record that we know of appears
in Babylonian cuneiform about 4000 years
ago about the times of Hammurabi and
describes a kind of divination known as
Lacan omen see where the diviner or the
baru as he was called would drop little
droplets of oil into a bowl of water and
then would very very carefully study the
nature and intricacies of this expanding
film across the surface and in doing so
thereby prophesy the fortunes of kings
and so it came to pass that it would
take a modern-day baru Bob Lawson to
decipher the nature of the intricacies
of this novel two-dimensional electron
system and lead to really what is a
truly beautiful theory of a new state of
matter
a novel quantum fluid with fractional
charged quasi particles and so please
join me in giving Bob a very hearty
welcome back home it's always a pleasure
to be back here at the place where they
number the buildings
I was many times in this this wonderful
lecture hall not listening to physics
listening to music mostly mi t--'s music
program is obviously very special I
remember vividly hearing Murray
gell-mann here confuse us all about
about about quarks it was at MIT that I
first heard ray Dingell talk about about
hetero structures and all the amazing
things they could do demonstrating
elementary quantum mechanics I later
heard some great stories about ray from
Horst and I hope any of you that put
enough liquor in him will get those
stories out now I apologize for this
lengthy wordy thing but I have a point
to make this this afternoon that is
summarized succinctly in it so it is
about my story of why the fractional
quantum Hall effect is important it's
fascinating for lots of reasons
but it's important in my view because it
shows experimentally this is the key
word experimentally that both particles
carrying a simple elementary fraction of
the electric charge of the electron and
interacting by gauge forces not
postulated in the underlying equations
of motion can arise in an emergent
manner as collective effects from
ordinary part
being the ordinary laws of quantum
mechanics
now both particles carrying fractional
quantum numbers and powerful gauge
fields between them are key postulates
of the standard model of elementary
particles something that is allegedly
fundamental in our universe and as I'm
going to claim this afternoon the
importance of these experiments is that
they impune this idea they suggest that
maybe such things in the universe itself
could be emergent which is to say could
not necessarily be fundamental at all
but just collective phenomena Frank will
check has a wonderful name for this he
calls it solid state imperialism and I
am the worst of the solid state
imperialists at least I hope so now on
that note let me start off with a with a
thing that's been a lot in the news
lately which is the theory of everything
now this is not the theory of everything
because there is no light in here and
there is no nuclear physics in here and
there is no gravity in here and there
are no weak interactions in here and so
forth but for chemistry and the world of
physics at people scales this might as
well be the theory of everything and
what I mean by everything is shown down
here now look everybody I apologize I
made this viewgraph in Stockholm the day
after we just had a press conference
that was completely monopolized by
professor Sen who won The Economist
Prize
and he had of course done fundamental
work in welfare policy and you can
imagine that nothing Beth sells better
in Sweden than talks about welfare
policy and so I was kind of a I was
feeling my oats here when I finished out
the things that the theory of everything
could describe okay notice what went by
Ebola virus okay now one of the things
that these oh by the way those of you
who are not physicists what is this this
is the elementary Schrodinger equation
for nonrelativistic matter and H the
equations of motion for this matter it
consists of kinetic energy of electrons
kinetic energy of ions columbic
attraction between them and also
coulombic repulsion x' between pairs of
light particles and that's it okay now
one of the things that this theory of
everything describes it is alleged is
this experiment this is not fun
cleansings
original quantum hall experiment but
it's conceptually the same so let's talk
about it as though it were so let me
remind everybody that the way the
experiments work is electric current is
forced along a sample that's typically
about a millimeter or vonlee order
several millimeters in size in fact this
this distance here was one millimeter in
the presence of a big magnetic field
pointing out of the board then one
measures two voltages this one between
this pad and the this one between those
two pads
that's the wiggly line here and also
between this pad and that one and that's
the line with the steps and those
voltages are measured as a function of
field strength magnetic field strength
and what the effect is
is that it's certain values of the
magnetic field or more precisely certain
ranges of it the potential drop in the
direction the current is going dies away
to nothing and at the same time the hall
conductance which is across the current
path becomes constant and what Klaus
discovered was that the value of this
constant which you can measure
accurately because it's constant is a
related to the current being forced by a
halt resistance that's multiples of
elementary constants in this case the
electric charge of the electron implies
constant now as of this moment the
accuracy if this experiment is about a
part in 10 to the 8th slightly less and
I ask you all to ponder how accuracy
that big could come out of these
equations
you see everybody whose solid studied
quantum physics knows that computing
things like air water and fire from this
underlying equation of everything is a
ludicrous undertaking it's too hard the
equations here cannot really be solved
accurately when the number of atoms
exceeds about 10 accurately means
apartment into the four maybe so
so beyond that it isn't possible to
solve first first principles a solution
so when we get elementary constants plox
constants and e coming out of a
measurement with 10 to the 20th
particles in it we have to pause and ask
why why is it so accurate
certainly you can't deduce this starting
from the underlying equations that's too
hard
now you mom may or may not know accuracy
of this kind occurs all the time all the
time in physics the first examples
actually come from chemistry the ones I
like to cite electrochemistry turns out
to be a very accurate way of measuring
the electric charge of the electron
however the the the sexy physics
examples mainly come from super
conductivity and the Josephson effect
the Josephson quantum of magnetic flux
is the most accurate quantity known in
mensuration aside from the speed of
light itself and so the plenty of
precedent in the physics literature for
many many particles giving rise to
accurate measurements of elementary
constants and in all those cases we know
the reason for this accuracy is higher
organizing principles the matter itself
is acting in some collective way that
you cannot deduce you cannot deduce from
these from these equations you can't you
can't go deductively from these
equations to this behavior because the
accuracy isn't there so the intellectual
problem that's posed by questions like
this is what is the principle why are
these experiments so accurate now a part
in 10 to the 8th you begin to think
about this a little bit and you see that
well the theory of everything that I
showed you actually has Corrections as
Corrections the biggest one is here
there's all practical purposes that spin
orbit coupling and things of that sort
in this material would be parts in 10 to
the 4
effects the radiation field actually is
bigger but it's subsumed by
renormalization effects in QED however
once we begin to worry about these
things then we begin to worry about all
the other all the other possible
Corrections to the to the experiment how
accurate can it get
what is limiting its accuracy if
anything now there is a an idea that is
well known to people who worry a lot
about the quantum mechanics of empty
space and that is that empty space isn't
empty empty space is full of stuff that
is the sum total of the accelerator
experiments that have been done since
the Second World War have told us that
space is a lot more like a piece of
glass than it is ideal Newtonian vacuum
it's filled with stuff and so when I
talk by analogy between issues we have
in the vacuum of space and issues that
happen in solids in fact this analogy is
apt and empty space is not empty in
exactly the same way that a solid is not
empty so all these Corrections to the
laws of physics in ordinary space matter
at least in principle they matter and
one of the questions we have to ask is
why don't they show up in mensuration
why is the why do all these why are all
these little Corrections to the
underlying equations irrelevant ok now
the answer of course is there's a
principle involved and in order to talk
about this principle I have to remind
you all of something you know or teach
you it if you don't and that is
something we call the principle of
adiabatic continue
so here's the problem suppose suppose
we've got some thing we want to
understand and it's very complicated but
like for example the hall conductance
but we know there's a principle involved
that makes it exact so we can imagine a
thought experiment where we perturb the
equations of motion slowly and
interpolate between lambda equals zero
which is the thing we're studying and
lambda equals one which is some
idealized some idealized limit of the
problem then if it turns out the thing
we're measuring is constant as I 80 of
attica Li deform the equations of motion
then I can understand what's going on
over here by studying what's going on
over here solid state physics we do this
all the time without calling it this
fancy name we call it modeling but I
have to be a little careful now because
the thing we're trying to understand is
an accuracy and so we can't be cavalier
about modeling and have to really think
hard about what continuation principle
allows us to understand something exact
in terms of a model now the model that
we like I would say let's say the model
would be I guess this end of the line
that we that we like to think about this
problem in terms of is the one shown
here so what this is is is ordinary non
relativistic electrons feeling a
magnetic field B and also moving in what
we call a dirt potential or random
potential now at the risk of telling a
joke that will bomb the dirt potential
is like pornography I can't define it
but I know it when I see it
in this case that random potential is
something that we could sketch but truth
is that in physics we don't know how to
define a random potential
we only know how to define the behavior
that you see in one write and the
behavior that you see in random
potentials has a name it's called
localization and localization is an
emergent principle that that we know to
be true because it's been seen in
experiments many many times now before
we get to that let's look at this this
random potential it turns out is is a
crucial to having Hall plateaus it's
very easy to show that if it's missing
then you don't have them so suppose
let's do that suppose the sample is
system is translationally invariant so
we have some density of particles in
there and a magnetic field well then you
all know you can run past it make a
Lorentz transformation then by the
relativity principle there will be in
the moving frame an electric field
across the sample a current going along
the sample and the ratio of the two
after some algebra turnouts
turns out to be the number of particles
per square centimeter divided by the
field strength times some elementary
constants so measurements like this Hall
effect measurements usually measure the
particle density and in fact this is a
standard and rather boring experiment
that one does in semiconductors to tell
how many extra carriers you have a
corollary of that idea then is the
quantum Hall effect can't occur in
samples that are perfect because if the
sample were perfect it would be
measuring the number of carriers in
there and the number of carriers in the
sample is not quantized
now let me now tell you all about
localization this unfortunately is
confused by dimensionality issues so let
me tell you the old lar back in the old
days when people were thinking about
three dimensional systems semiconductors
in particular the idea of localization
was born I was born in the mind of Phil
Anderson the basic idea of it is that
eigen states of one electron quantum
mechanics which is what we're talking
about here come in two varieties there
are extended States and localized ones
extended states are contiguous from one
side of the sample to the other and they
are capable of carrying electric current
localized states are the opposite they
are not contiguous from one side of the
sample to the other and they are not
capable of carrying electric current now
in in an actual sample it is found
experimentally that not only is this
true but there is an a energy scale
called the mobility edge below which all
the states are localized and above which
all the end states are extended and they
the way the system approaches these this
edge is part and parcel of the mental
insulator transition in disordered one
electron problems now there was in the
old days lore about this that you
couldn't have localized in extended
States at the same energy because if you
did then the tiniest amount of
perturbation would mix them and you'd
have two extended States but nobody knew
whether to believe that law or not so
the way it came down eventually was that
this this was adopted as true because
the experiments told us it was true
localization is a phenomenon that
happens in nature that you cannot deduce
from microscopic s-- you can get part of
the way there if you cheat and make some
assumptions about what a random
potential is but the truth is we don't
know how to do that
so the right way to look at localization
is not as a theoretical idea so much as
an established experimental fact now
what happens in a magnetic field well at
the time of this experiment nobody knew
nobody knew what should happen and there
were some things we did know which was
the random potential should have taken
Landau levels and broadened them Landau
levels or highly degenerate manifolds of
states and the first thing a
perturbation does to degenerate states
as it breaks the degeneracy so everybody
expected the density of states of this
one electron problem to look something
like this
and actually I think it's fair to say in
the beginning everybody expected
everything to be localized that it
should be have been localized in the
tail region was completely obvious from
anybody's point of view that there
should be localization in the center was
very non obvious the [ __ ] Singh
experiments told us that it was not so
that there were extended states in the
Centers of these Landau bands and the
reason is because it conducted
electricity so we knew that it must do
so so there were extended state bans
there but we didn't know much more about
that in those days it was one year I
know I guess my - more like two years
after the publication of the famous Gang
of Four paper predicting or asserting
that localization must be complete
in two dimensions and we are in fact in
two dimensions in this problem so many
people felt that localization should
have been complete and something else
must have been going on now as I said
the experiments told us otherwise and
now in the light of hindsight we
understand that localization physics is
different in magnetic fields than it is
in their absence and in particular this
problem has a density of states which
actually looks like I've drawn it
it's tales of extent of localized states
separated by distinct bands of extended
ones now how do you get perfection out
of imperfection this is relevant to the
fractional quantum Hall effect so let me
lead you down to this this idea
historically here is this now-infamous
argument due to me which accounts for
why localization makes exact
quantization of hall conductance and as
this horse said the essence of it is
that the system can be made by a thought
experiment into a charge meter the
thought experiment which does that is
illustrated here so we imagine wrapping
the the quantum Hall system into a loop
there's a magnetic field coming out of
the surface of this loop I don't know
how you do that just do it and we will
imagine filling up these one electron
States up to some chemical potential
that is in the localized State band now
rather than computing currents which is
hard let us compute energies and then
take the adiabatic derivative of the
total energy of the system with respect
to a little bit of magnetic flux that's
poked through the center this is not
hard
understand it's just Faraday's laws of
induction if when you change the the the
flux through the center there is some
EMF that winds around the loop and if
there's current going that it'll do work
on it why is this allowed
well it's allowed by the fact that the
system doesn't dissipate so so that if
we are in a region of the localized
States then the conductance which is to
say the dissipative part of the response
function has to be identically 0 because
localized
things are insulators and so that means
that this flux can be put into the loop
and out adiabatic Li so it's because
there's no dissipation that adiabatic
derivative makes sense now while one is
doing this adiabatic derivative the
localized states do nothing and the
reason for that is that since they go
down they don't go around the loop they
can't tell the difference between
addition of flux and a gauge
transformation so it's exactly true that
the localized States contribute nothing
to the adiabatic derivative and for that
reason I can just erase them which I've
done here now we've got a much nicer
problem which is little bands of states
separated by finite gaps in which the
chemical potential lies now as I do this
adiabatic derivative it is not possible
for a state to cross the gap adiabatic
Li the reason for that is that if it did
it would be coincident and energy with a
localized state and therefore would have
to be localized so that's out so this
little localized state region here is
like a brick wall it prevents adiabatic
motion of states and so that means when
I wind the flux the only state motion
that's allowed is from one edge to the
other now the trick to making this
calculate
and simple is to make the sample big
enough that the adiabatic derivative can
be replaced by differential where the
denominator is a flux quantum doing this
means that adiabatic the changing slowly
slowly slowly stop maps the Hamiltonian
back to itself up to a gauge
transformation and this means that the
system can have changed its energy only
by repopulating the original states but
that is only possible at edges because
only at the edges are there states at
the Fermi energy so the current carried
is 1 over C times the change in energy
which is the number of electrons the
number of states which are transferred
from one side of the sample to the other
times the chemical potential difference
between the two sides divided by a flux
quantum which is the answer so in this
view of accurate quantization the proof
if you will that localization physics
will not will not change the quantum of
hall conductance even though the number
of states is changing as is their
occupation is that the experiment
measures the charge of the electron the
electron the quantum of hall conductance
is quantized because the electric charge
of the electron is quantized and the
quanta can be viewed in this context is
the same now that's historical
perspective you can imagine you can
imagine my surprise great joy actually
when I got this preprint from Horst and
Dan announcing their discovery the
fractional quantum Hall effect so what
you see here are the this experiment is
just the same as I showed you we're
sending a current along the axis
measuring voltages the voltage drop in
the director
the current flow is shown here the hall
voltage between that pad and that one is
shown here and down at the left you see
[ __ ] sings effect and then up here where
there should have been nothing you see a
new feature developing and a dip in the
parallel conductance corresponding to it
it's failing to get deeper as you lower
the temperature there's no no no we
checked all that we check for
nonlinearities it looks very good you'll
see it hasn't gotten to zero yet in this
experiment it's on its way obviously but
hasn't gotten there so I made a guess
they based on based on my knowledge of
these guys and also the way the
experiment was going naming that
localization physics was also happening
here and then it would be complete when
the temperature was lowered also if you
look at this line just with your eye you
know Center it with your eye you'll see
it's already one percent accurate and
that was already too much there should
have not there should have been no
reason for it to be one percent accurate
even even that accurate so there was
every reason to believe that the effect
was the same as [ __ ] sings effect except
at the wrong fraction the filling factor
rather than being an integer was
one-third now Horst here's it got the
experiments got better
here is a later one
so the guess was right here's a later
one showing the 1/3 plateau very well
developed it's very very deep minimum
here and you can notice also subsidiary
fractions here at two fifths and three
sevens now as the samples improved
fractions of all sorts began popping out
and horse
likes to say well what a neat thing it
was that good old Bob invented this this
equation to explain it all but the truth
is I didn't and even worse than that I
was really lucky in fact the world was
lucky that the samples were so lousy
when the original experiment was done
because had we known about all these
other fractions we've been in very
confused so anyway it was a lucky break
for lucky break for everybody that the
this 1/3 just happened to be the biggest
one and therefore the most obvious now
how accurate is this experiment well as
I told you you can eyeball it the
original ones or a percent the modern
air bar is about a part in ten to the
fifth and most of us see the only
impediment to getting it better being
the temperatures to which you can cool
the 2d electron gas that means we have
the same problem with the accuracy of
this fractional Hall plateau that we had
with the integer wands that it's already
too inaccurate to be explained by
modeling there really must be a
principle involved to make it so
accurate unfortunately the localization
principle that we knew won't work
here because any problem that can be a
diabatic lee continued to
non-interacting electrons must have
integer plateaus that's the essence of
the thought experiment that I showed you
that means that this quantum state
whatever it is is not continual to
non-interacting electrons but is rather
some sort of many-body effect that
involves the Coulomb interactions now
by far the easiest theory to make right
now is that this effect is the same as
this one except the thing being
localized is not an electron but a piece
of an electron and an elementary
excitation of the problem that has
fractional charge now please note that
I'm talking in the sense of the
principle of adiabatic continued ability
so I'm imagining a limit of the problem
where the objects if you will elementary
excitations become non interacting and
free in that case we have localization
physics just as before but not
localization of electrons but instead
localizations of the elementary
excitations of this state whatever it is
now I can't emphasize too strongly that
the reason to believe this is the
experiments not the theory that I'm
about to show you the experiments tell
you that there must be fractionally
charged excitations in the problem
because there is no other way out of
accounting for the accuracy the accuracy
is the key thing there has to be a
principle the principle you have
available is localization localization
of things deformable two electrons free
electrons won't work as a matter of
principle so by far the easiest thing
left is just you have a new vacuum where
the excitation czar fractional now all
that was left now was to invent a
prototype that everybody could
understand now you folks probably many
of you are too young to remember that in
those days there was already a big
literature on fractionally charged
excitations that goes way way back to
papers on solitons by Jack even rebbe
done here actually and also work done by
Bob schrieffer at Santa Barbara in
systems which had systems which have
what we call discrete broken symmetries
in them
so the idea that there should be vacuum
with fractionally charged excitations is
not originally to me it's due to people
who went before me a chiefly particle
physics and Bob's reefer
so one already knew that the idea was
not nuts the only thing left was to to
figure out what it might be now I should
tell you when I knew about the soliton
work and so I made a theory of this
effect based on an analogy with
fractional quantization in solitons and
I sent it into phys Rev letters and I
like to say thank God
the referee rejected it I know later
that this referee was Steve Kittleson
and Steve pointed out well that your
discrete symmetry breaking that you've
made in your theory is really continuous
image breaking it's like the stripe idea
and that means it's got a pin and
therefore it wouldn't conduct
electricity and so the whole idea is
nonsense so I got this referee report I
said well unfortunately he's right so I
need to go think about it tomorrow so I
thought well this thing experiments are
telling us it has a great big energy gap
so when things have energy gaps you can
get to first base and modeling them just
by brute force so I thought okay let's
try to solve the problem by computer
starting with one electron and I can do
then let's do two I did two that turns
out to be easy if you do that on paper
what does that mean nothing in some of
hello right then three then four so so
the model Hamiltonian one couldn't study
is just a few electrons that are
repelling each other columbic li and for
balance let's put a little pressure in
here to keep them keep them in
in these old calculations there are two
energy scales there's a so-called
cyclotron frequency and a Coulomb energy
which is e squared over the length
associated with that harmonic oscillator
energy and the limit we usually prefer
as theorists as is this one where the
cyclotron energy is much larger than the
Coulomb energy even though in real
samples were not always deeply in that
limit but it doesn't matter because of
the adiabatic continued ability this is
the right limit to be in so so I studied
looked at these guys and solve them and
got the wave functions out and I'll show
them here there they are these wave
functions I'm showing you are completely
meaningless I just like to show them
then I found those sure enough the the
little cluster is kind of doing what the
experiments do as you increase the
pressure going this way the mean square
area changes and jumps and the and the
angular momentum also changes and jumps
as though it's contracting it has
preferred densities and it's contracting
discretely so I thought that's good then
I said okay well that's that's what's
what's happening then maybe something
like this thing down here is the ground
state so I knew this wave function is
exact when the number of particles is 2
it's pretty close when the number of
particles was 3 4 or 5 and 6 so I spent
several weeks trying to prove that it
was the exact ground state of the
relevant Hamiltonian relevant
Hamiltonian in this case is
non-interacting electrons plus a little
bit of Coulomb balance potential in the
background gel IAM basically
+ pairwise Coulomb forces
and it wouldn't work and it wouldn't
work and it wouldn't work and finally I
said well it's not I'm not gonna work
okay this doesn't work whose great idea
but failed so I went in the physics
library at Livermore and began reading
books on helium I thought oh well
helium's like this and I could learn
from helium and the very first book I
pulled down was Gene Fein Berg's book on
many-body theory and I opened it at
random and there on the very page I had
opened was this wave function it turns
out that this functional form for many
body problems is used very commonly it's
called Jastrow form and it's it's
variational so I thought oh my god
that's it the wave function isn't exact
wave functions and never many body
physics never are so the thing is
variational so I quickly went to find
out how good it was now just so you
folks know what's written here a z1
whose en are the locations of the
electrons in the plane expressed as
complex numbers so this is a pairwise
difference raised to a power the power
has to be an odd integer and then
because of the background magnetic field
it has to be cancelled by an exponential
one for each electron and the length
scale and this experiment is the
magnetic length which has been set to
one so as luck would have it I was in a
laboratory that specializes in plasma
physics and the nature of the
calculations that I had to do were all
the same as those done in dense plasmas
so I went to my plasma buddies forrest
rodgers and Hugh DeWitt and asked them
how to calculate and they showed me and
then one by one things began to fall
into place so the we square the wave
function to get the probability to find
the electrons at various positions
integrate out all but one of those
coordinates and we get the density
charge density of the of the state and
sure enough it was exactly uniform out
to the boundary and the density is
exactly what we want it's one of the
ideal density of a field and a level the
first non-trivial value of M by the way
is three which is the one-third effect
also one can integrate out all but two
of the coordinates and get what's called
the pair correlation functions and
that's important for four well here's
what it looks like so what this is is
this is a prop this is the density of
the fluid given that one of the function
of distance given that one of the
particles is at the origin so in an
electron gas lingo this is the exchange
correlation whole of the gas and what
you see is that the electrons avoid each
other so one electron is at the origin
then the other electrons avoid it
although in the M equals three state
which is the interesting one they pile
up a little bit at the near neighbor
position so once you have this function
then you can weight it by 1 over R to
get the energy now just to show you
there was at the time a strawman which
was he de Fukuyama's he'd a infill
Plattsmouth i guess there hartree-fock
calculations for the victor crystal and
so it was possible to weight this pair
distribution function by 1 over r and
find that the wave function I made was a
little better energetically because it
keeps the particles a little bit farther
apart than the crystal
and so here is total energy as a
function of filling factor here is the
strawman victor crystal energy down at
the bottom is the one-third state I
constructed one fifth looks like it's
it's it's better and then one seventh
it's a little hard to tell okay so on
the basis of this calculation I
predicted that there should be one more
of these fractions namely one at
one-fifth and when I finished this
calculation I phoned up Horst I said
Horst Horst I think there's another
fraction he said really what I said
one-fifth he said well it's close what
had happened in the meantime was that
these guys had discovered the famous 2/5
state which unfortunately I did not
predict and then they began to find all
sorts of fractions that I didn't predict
and didn't find 1/5 and that was that
was as my father used to say cheap
thrills and they didn't find it and they
didn't find it and they didn't find it
and then finally I believe it was Emilio
um as Mendes found it in this experiment
now there are better wait wait wait
wait there are better there are better
experiments I just wanted to show this
one to demonstrate the the links to
which theorists will go to declare
victory of their theories okay in fact
modern samples have a nice nice Plateau
here although it is one of the weakest
ones ever ever found well let's just get
that right off okay
now what about the fractionally charged
excitations turns out you get those for
free once you have a once you have a
uniform state with an energy gap then
you can imagine a little thought
experiment where you poke the sample
with an infinitely thin solenoid
adiabatic li wind a little flux of
magnetic flux through it a whole flux
quantum and then once you've done that
again the Hamiltonian has returned to
itself just like it is in the in the
loop problem and so you can remove the
solenoid by gauge transformation and
this process gives an excitation of
charge plus or minus 1/3 depending on
which way you wind the basic reason for
this is the following that the winding
process does something complicated near
the solenoid you don't understand but
far away from the solenoid the effect is
very simple it's exactly the same as in
the integral quantum Hall effect it just
takes the state and moves it over my 1
orbital and so the net charge
transported through an imaginary Gauss's
law box here is is the average charge
per orbital of the ground state which in
this case was one third one thing led to
another and I cooked up these
variational wave functions for the
positive and negative quasi particle Z
naught here is not a variable
it's a place locating the center of this
particle so it's a quantum number these
wave functions came out of the blue they
were just the simplest approximations I
could think of that would look something
like this thought experiment later
Duncan Hall Dana nedra's I did numerical
calculations on the problem and found
out these wave functions were vastly
better than they had any right to be so
these are actually pretty good
representations of the of the problem
with Coulomb interactions what these
particles look like is this this is what
they look like this is a plot of charge
density versus how far you are from the
center of the particle and the we want
to look at the solid line here that's
the positively charged one what you see
is near the center of it there is a
place where the charge density of the
fluid is missing and when you add up the
deficit it's exactly a third the quasi
whole wave function is this dashed line
and it's the opposite the charge density
of the vacuum near the center is in
excess and when you added up the amount
in excess is exactly one-third
now with these wave functions then it's
possible to compute the Coulomb
repulsion of the piled up charge with
itself and thus and then compare it with
measurements of the energy to make such
a particle these measurements
measurements which do that or which we
believe do that are shown here these is
a plot of the parallel resistance versus
one over temperature dot in the dead
center in in you know Plateau and what
you see is as you cool it off which goes
to the right there's a region where you
get a reneus behavior transitioning to
what we call variable range hopping
behavior at lower temperatures both of
these behaviors have law associated with
them this is a strong localization
effect and this is what you expect to
get very generally with thermal
activation of particles from a chemical
potential up to a mobility edge the
mobility edge distance ought to be
something like the gap of the state
someone can take this slope
and convert it into an energy gap and
compare it with what one gets in theory
now when this was first done it didn't
work so well this is a plot of measured
activation gap versus field strength
here are the measurements down here and
the theory is this dashed line however
shortly thereafter Alan McDonald
realized that there's a the models too
crowed there's a big effect missing
which is the thickness of the of the 2d
electron gas at the vertical direction
so and has a finite thickness and when
one takes that into account
good hefty fraction of the deficit goes
away and the rest of it at least I just
described to well being good enough for
government work because these this
relation of the mobility edge energy to
the actual gap is a little vague in the
first place being comparable in size is
enough especially when the trend is
right notice everybody pleased at the
energy scale we're talking about here is
quite low quite low compared with the
natural Coulomb energy scale so the the
fact that it that has this trend with
magnetic field and it's also the right
size is very significant so we got that
right now the last thing I want to talk
about as gauge forces it somehow came to
pass in the development of composite
fermions which are perfectly right by
the way that the following amazing
property of these quasi particles got an
overlooked I think this has always
struck me as one of the most important
and in most amazing properties of these
objects and that is that they exert
forces on each other
they're velocity-dependent this was
first figured out by Frank we'll check
and Dan aromas and Bob schrieffer who
took the trouble of adiabatically
exchanging two of these quasiparticles
theoretically and discovering that the
so-called berry phase for adiabatic
exchange was a fraction in this
experiment you get an odd multiple of Pi
when the particles are fermions an even
multiple of Pi when they're bosons this
particular multiple was neither one
between it's a fraction and it's a
fraction associated with the with the
charge of the particle what that means
physically is that when one of these
particles moves in the presence of
another it feels a fictitious vector
potential as though there were a
solenoid being carried by the stationary
particle carrying a fraction of the
elementary flux quantum where the
fraction is associated with the charge
now the really neat thing about
fractional statistics was that it was
figured out about this about the same
time but I think actually before
empirically by Bert Halpern through
graphs like this Bert figured out that
if the fractional statistics were
present then the quasi particles
themselves could reckon dense into new
fractions and those fractions would come
out to be the observed ones namely 2/5
3/7 and so forth if they had these
solenoid solenoid 'el forces on them so
this is a total energy calculation
pulled out of one of Bert's papers and
we don't have to worry about the details
of it just DotA's that it has some
interesting features at the fractions at
which the so called hierarchical states
occur now my interpretation of this
state of affairs
has really not not changed over the many
years namely that the observation of
these fractions other than one-third
amounts to experimental proof that the
gauge forces are there when the gauge
forces actually are emergent in this
problem even though there is more than
one way to describe it the physics of
emergent velocity dependent forces is
definitely present in the problem and
has physical measurable effects okay now
we go back to the the premise now after
all is said and done what have we
learned well like most wonderful things
in physics this particular discovery has
implications okay it was not expected it
was completely out of the blue it has
very many interesting aspects
particularly those relevant to small
devices and solid-state physics
semiconductor engineering and so forth
but the thing that matters to me mostly
as a theorist are is the bigger issue of
where the strange rules of the vacuum
might come from and always when you have
an experiment God is on your side
in this case we do have experiments we
have accurate quantization which is
telling us what that there are indeed
fractionally charged objects in the
world that are collective and late
nature they have carry a quantum of
charge that is as exact as the electric
charge itself of the electron itself and
they also have very powerful forces
between them which are not pasta lated
in the underlying equations of motion
but simply emerge a new vacuum and a new
kind fundamentally new kind of quantum
emergence at least for me and I hope
you to eventually this has been an
exceedingly thought-provoking thing and
I believe in hope that it will have
major implications for physics of all
kinds as we move into the next century
and millennium all right that's all I
have to say thank you very much for
[Applause]
and we have time I think for a couple of
questions yes Patrick
yeah maybe I lied sorry Patrick we have
a parity problem wait wait wait
yeah here we go here we go
picture the head the loop right
excellent question let me answer that
now so that your students will
understand this henceforth okay let me
answer this now Patrick because as this
I know you all should know that Patrick
and I have been arguing about this for
10 years well yeah right
my hair is greater than yours so I can't
admit it the answer of course is that
when the loop is small so that there's a
balm Aharon effect then the hall
conductance is not quantized yep
yes but that's a no-brainer Patrick wait
wait wait wait wait Patrick this is
already known if you have something
that's that's one or two atoms one or
two magnetic lengths big there isn't any
quantization of anything ah interesting
now interesting question now that nobody
knows better the you know when you Kate
I'm sorry I'm preaching here look I
don't know how it depends on Ellen what
I know is that when the sample is too
small you can see it it's there and
therefore the quantization argument is
false so one has to be in the
thermodynamic limit for the argument to
work and that's because localization is
a thermodynamic concept now you're
absolutely right that the disappearance
of the bow Maharana effect in the
thermodynamic limit is part of the
argument okay
and I might I guess the best answer I
can give you is like localization see I
can't prove that either okay but the
scaling hypothesis leads me to plus
experimental facts they lead me to
believe very strongly in in localization
and so by the same token I'd say that
that if we have a loop that's a
centimeter in size I assure you you will
never see the bow Maharana effect I
assure you
oh yes now ray ah now ray I made ray a
bet that of an effect that he saw was
due to what did I say I said it was time
time-dependent delays and transport and
ray bet made me this bet in public at a
semiconductor meeting and and then well
should I tell the rest of the story ray
well I don't know I think probably ought
to pay each other 50 bucks and then go
have a beer but what actually happened
was
the experiment was the voltage in the
experiment was driven a little too hard
and the effect was an artifact of the
measurement so whose culpable their it
true it's a different artifact but but I
say if you demand the hundred dollars
under those circumstances you are a
scoundrel I think we should buy each
other a beer and call it a day rare
[Laughter]
right Yeah right I think I don't know
[Applause]